Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu Ausgabe 6undneunzig von Raumzeit und ja äh heute geht's. Wie sollte es anders sein? Wieder um ein neues Thema und in gewisser Hinsicht knüpfen wir auch an letzte Sendungen an.
Trotzdem,
steigen wir in eine Wissenschaft ein, die wir schon mal beleuchtet haben in Raumzeiten ähsechzig, habe ich nämlich mit Heike Rauer gesprochen und da ging's um Exoplaneten und wir haben uns mal so angeschaut, wie sich diese Szene entwickelt, die ja irgendwie erst 1995 so richtig das
Licht der Welt gesehen hat. Ja und äh sich dann sehr schnell entwickelt hat und wir haben viel über Techniken geredet, wie man diese Exoplaneten entdeckt.
Ein bisschen tiefer eintauchen und mal schauen was eigentlich sich in den letzten,
fünf Jahren vor allem getan hat, seitdem diese Sendung aufgenommen wurde und dazu begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich die Lena-Lena Noak. Hallo.
Ja hallo, freut mich sehr hier zu sein.
Mich auch, ähm denn äh du bist ja äh anerkannte Expertin in diesem Bereich, äh arbeitest an der FU Berlin, wenn ich das richtig äh sehe im Institut für Geowissenschaften, bist dort Professorin,
wie's so schön heißt,
Das ist äh im Maus voll, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Sprich mit allen Worten ähm hat an den ideologischen Realitäten von Planeten dran.
Da würde man dann eigentlich mal vermuten, da steckt ja dann wahrscheinlich so eine Lebensgeschichte mit Biologiestudium dahinter, aber dem scheint ja auch nicht so zu sein, oder?
Nee, tatsächlich überhaupt nicht. Ähm als ich schon klein war, habe ich mich immer gefragt, was möchte ich später werden? Und da hatte ich eigentlich nur zwei Optionen. Astronauten oder Mathematiklehrerin?
So so diese klassischen äh Optionen so.
Klassischen Optionen ganz genau. Ich bin dann tatsächlich erstmal in die Richtung Mathematik gegangen, habe eine Humutuniversität, Mathematik studiert,
Aber mein Fable für Planetenwissenschaften, für Astronomie, das hat mich mein ganzes Leben begleitet. Also das da wollte ich so unglaublich gerne was mit machen,
Und als das Mathematikstudium langsam Richtung Ende ging, war dann die Frage, okay, gehe ich in eine Versicherung, arbeite ich für eine Bank,
oder zwei Gebäude weiter. Dort äh war tatsächlich das DLR Institut für Planetenforschung.
Und ähm da hat's mich einfach hingezogen, da war ich bei der langen Nacht der Wissenschaften immer. Ich fand das unglaublich spannend, was dort gemacht wurde,
und äh dann hat's tatsächlich auch geklappt, dass ich nach dem Studium, nach dem Mathematikstudium als Quereinsteigerin, dort ähm in der Arbeitsgruppe für die Planeten Physik äh angesiedelt wurde. Eine Doktorarbeit geschrieben habe,
mich dann tatsächlich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt hab, was passiert eigentlich im Inneren von Planeten,
Gesteinsplaneten, also Planeten wie Erde, Venus, Maß in unserem Sonnensystem.
Was ich total faszinierend fand, also im Mathematikstudium ähm bin ich auch so ein bisschen mehr in die Programmiererrichtung gegangen, also nennt sich das,
und ähm habe mich dort damit beschäftigt, wenn man ein gebogenes Rohr hat, wie dann Flüssigkeiten, in welcher Geschwindigkeit dort langfließen und ob Turbulenzen entstehen und so weiter.
Und ähm dann habe ich mich beim DLR vorgestellt und habe gelernt, tatsächlich erst in dem Moment, dass auf ganz langen geologischen Zeitsgeilen, also wirklich Millionen bis Milliarden Jahren im Inneren von der Erde, der Gesteins meinte sich ziemlich ähnlich.
Und das fand ich unglaublich faszinierend. Also das.
Ähnlich bewegt wie das Wasser im Rohr.
Ganz genau, also genau diese Bewegungen, dass man also Konjktionen hat, dass tatsächlich Material sich bewegt. Wie gesagt, es ist eine völlig andere Geschwindigkeit, von der wir da reden. Das sind so Zentimeter pro Jahr Geschwindigkeit,
Aber genau das passiert in der Erde auch und das das fand ich unglaublich interessant, unglaublich spannend.
Und äh dadurch bin ich dann eingestiegen in das Gebiet, dass man das Innere oder die Mantelkonvention im Inneren von diesem Planeten modelliert,
Das hängt mit ganz vielen Themen Spektrin zusammen, zum Beispiel die Frage, warum wir Plattentektorik auf der Erde haben. Hängt halt damit zusammen, wie sich die Massengesteinsmassen im Mantel von der Erde, also ein Gesteinsmantel, von der Erde, bewegen.
Oder wie viel Vokanismus wir haben, hängt genauso damit zusammen,
Und ähm das finde ich so toll, dass wir an der Oberfläche von von der Erde oder auch von anderen Planeten Hinweise darauf bekommen, was tatsächlich im Inneren vom Planeten passiert.
Wann war diese Doktorarbeit?
Das habe ich 2tausend8 angefangen und ähm 2tausend12 dann beendet.
Okay, das heißt zu dem Zeitpunkt war auch schon klar, Exoplaneten gibt es.
Ganz genau. Und das hat auch meine Doktorarbeit von Anfang an beeinflusst, äh weil tatsächlich im ersten Jahr würde ich sagen, als meine Doktorarbeit angefangen habe,
hat denn genannt sie war in der involviert die den ersten Gesteinsplaneten entdeckt hat,
hat es natürlich sofort angesteckt äh mit ihrem Interesse und äh mit der Euphorie.
Ähm wir den ersten Planeten außerhalb von unserem Sonnensystem gefunden haben, von dem wir ziemlich genau wissen, dass es ein Gesteinsplanet sein muss.
Warum wussten wir das?
Das ist zwar Einheit von den wenigen Planeten, ähm auch heute haben wir noch nicht so wahnsinnig viele davon, wo wir die Masse und den Radius relativ genau bestimmen konnten,
ähm das äh ist für tatsächlich dazu, dass wir wissen, wie schwer ist der Planet,
und ähm wenn wir uns einfach im Sonnensystem anschauen, äh wie sich so diese Schwere oder die Dichte von dem Planeten von Merkur bis ganz weit nach draußen äh Uranus Neptun verschiebt,
sieht man, dass die die höchste Dichte ähm taucht tatsächlich bei den Gesteinsplaneten auf,
und ähm das können wir dann damit auch äh vergleichen mit den Dichten, die wir dann von Exoplaneten messen und wissen, okay, entweder muss es halt ganz große Wassermengen geben oder Gasmengen, wie jetzt beim Jupiter zum Beispiel,
Oder ist es so eine hohe Dichte, dass man's nur erklären kann, dass der Planet aus ähm Gemisch, aus Eisen ähm ähm Gestein besteht.
Mhm. Bevor wir auf diese ganzen äh Details äh kommen, um vielleicht das nochmal kurz äh abzuschließen, sodass die Doktorarbeit gemacht. Wann kam diese Professur dann in der FU dazu?
Ein paar Jahre später, ich war erstmal für fünf Jahre im Ausland ähm in Belgien, in Brüssel.
Und ähm habe dann dort schon meine eigene Forschungsrichtung entwickeln können und konnte dann 2017 die Professur an der FU Berlin übernehmen,
und äh jetzt auch meine eigene Arbeitsgruppe aufbauen und.
Professor ist jetzt genau für was? Für welche Disziplin?
Das ist tatsächlich für diese geodynamische Modellierung auf basierend auf der Information, die wir von den Materialien im Inneren haben, also Mineralphysik, um globale, planetare Prozesse zu verstehen, deswegen auch dieser sehr, sehr lange und komplizierte Name.
Ja, aber gab's den sozusagen schon schon immer, ist das eine relativ neue Lehrstuhl.
Das war tatsächlich geplant als Junior-Professur. Ähm die jetzt als Universitätsprofessur weiterläuft. Also das gab's tatsächlich vorher noch nicht. Okay, das heißt, da ist auch so das ist was.
Okay, das heißt, da ist auch schon schon Exo-Planeten sozusagen schon im äh im Hinterkopf oder.
Ganz genau. Mhm.
Im Vorderkopf vielleicht. Genau und ähm du hast aber jetzt auch schon bei Missionen quasi mitgearbeitet oder zugearbeitet, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also ich ähm habe halt bei der Platomission ähm bin ich im ähm.
Also Plato ist die ähm Exoplanetenmission der Esa, die in Planung ist. Sie soll irgendwie 2026 starten.
Genau, genau und da bin ich im Konsortium involviert und ähm,
da ging's für mich auch darum, es war auch während meiner Doktorarbeit noch ähm zu schauen, warum brauchen wir eigentlich die Platemission,
brauchen wir also Plate wird ähm viele neue Planeten entdecken, auch um sonnenähnliche Sterne, vor allem äh auch kleinere Planeten Planeten, die ungefähr so groß sind wie die Erde,
Das aber mit einer sehr hohen Genauigkeit den Radius bestimmen beziehungsweise später dann mit Nachfolgemessung dann äh wird auch die Masse relativ,
bestimmt werden und die Frage ist, warum brauchen wir das eigentlich? Warum müssen wir wissen ob äh einen Planet zu groß wie der Mars ist oder so groß wie die Erde.
Warum warum ist das überhaupt wichtig? Und ähm dadurch hat mich ähm das dann auch sehr stark in die Exoplanetenrichtung geschoben in meiner Forschung,
diese Fragestellung, also die gerade diese Sachen, die wir beobachten können,
Sind nicht viele für Exoplaneten. Ähm es gibt ein paar Daten, die wir finden können, aber wir haben natürlich nicht die gleiche äh Auswahl an Daten, als wenn wir jetzt zum Mars fliegen würden und auf der Oberfläche landen.
Aber was sagen uns die Daten tatsächlich aus über diese Planeten? Und das ist das, womit ich mich beschäftige.
Dann würde ich ganz gerne noch mal so zum Einstieg, weil ich hatte das mit der Heike Rauer zwar auch schon gemacht, aber die Geschwindigkeit der Entwicklung ist hier so schnell, deswegen ist es, glaube ich, ganz sinnvoll, das noch mal so ein bisschen ähm zusammenzufassen.
Wie sich das hierzu entwickelt hat seit 1995. Dann ging's äh ja los. Dort wurde der erste Planet um einen sonnenähnlichen äh Stern.
Gefunden. Gab's auch einen Nobelpreis für, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau, vor zwei Jahren.
Aha. Ähm ja, kann man mal machen. Was hat das ausgelöst? Wie ging's weiter und wo sind wir jetzt?
Also das ist Experte geben könnte oder müsste, darüber hat man natürlich schon lange spekuliert gehabt, ganz klar und ähm die ersten exoplanierten Detektionen war tatsächlich äh in den Ende von den achtziger Jahren,
Aber damals war man sich so unsicher. Man hat nicht geglaubt, dass man wirklich einen Exemplar Planeten gefund,
es sind ja auch sehr große Störsignale, mit denen man umgehen muss und ähm der Planet wurde tatsächlich erst äh ja 20 Jahre später ungefähr äh bestätigt.
Man hat ihn gesehen, man man meinte, es könnte das.
Gesehen, da ist was. Genau, aber man konnte es nicht eindeutig sagen und ähm.
Keinen Nobelpreis.
Gab's keinen Nobelpreis. Ähm es wurde auch ein paar Jahre später um einen Posausterstern herum. Auch Exoplaneten äh gefunden.
Aber das ist nicht so spannend, ne, also das ist äh bewohnbar sind diese Planeten nicht, wenn man einen Posausterstern direkt neben sich hat, ne. Also die Strahlung, die da auf einen zukommt, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden.
Okay.
95 war jetzt nicht nur das Tolle, dass halt wirklich ein Exot Planet um ein so einen ähnlichen Stern gefunden wurde, sondern den Exoplanet, der dort eigentlich nichts zu suchen hatte.
Wein in Gasriese, wie man sich den Jupiter vorstellen muss, allerdings so nah am Stern dran, dass er eine extrem heiße Temperatur hat,
man musste die gesamte Überlegung wie sich Planeten bilden, wo sich Planeten bilden, wie ähm,
normal unser System ist im Vergleich zu anderen Sternsystem komplett überdenken,
Und dafür ist äh der Nobelpreis mehr als gerechtfertigt, auf jeden Fall.
Und ähm danach ähm so die nächsten zehn Jahre wurden zwar immer mehr Planeten entdeckt, auch mit unterschiedlichen Methoden und je nachdem, welche Methode man verwendet hat, wusste man äh ungefähr, was die Masse ist oder die die minimale Masse,
oder den Radius.
Und ähm nur wenn man unterschiedliche Methoden miteinander kombiniert, ähm kann man tatsächlich die Masse und den Radius von dem Planeten relativ genau bestimmen und kriegt dann wirklich eine Vorstellung, um was für eine Planetenklasse handelt es sich da eigentlich?
Und da war dann der Durchbruch ähm ja gut zehn Jahre später ähm riesengroß, also erst von der Coro Mission ähm äh Coro sieben B und kurz danach von der Keplermission, die ja auch tausende von Exoplaneten entdeckt hat, äh über zehn Jahre hinweg,
hat dann auch den also auch ein Gesteinsplaneten entdeckt, von dem wir uns wirklich sicher sind, ähm dass er hauptsächlich aus äh Gestein und Metallen, also hauptsächlich Eisen wahrscheinlich besteht.
Wenn man sich jetzt mal unsere Galaxis vorstellt, wie weit schauen wir, wo sind bisher die Planeten entdeckt worden, wie nah dran ist das an uns.
Also sehr unterschiedlich. Ähm tatsächlich in dem nächsten Nachbarstern von uns im Alpha Zentauri-System. Dort haben wir mindestens ein Exempel Planeten gefunden, also es ist die in der direkten Nachbarschaft.
Und äh geht aber weiter über hunderte, tausende von Lichtjahre entfernt. Auch dort sind immer noch Experienten gefunden worden.
Das Problem ist, ähm je näher sie dran sind, desto besser können wir sie beobachten,
Also das bedeutet zum einen, dass wir halt die die Messung für für den Radius, äh wenn es ein Planet ist, der von unserer Sicht aus vor dem Stern,
die Umlaufbahn äh hat und dementsprechend wir an den Transitz von diesem Planeten beobachten können. Das hilft uns, den Radius zu bestimmen,
oder ähm wir können auch uns anschauen, wie bewegt sich ein Stern im,
im Weltraum und wenn praktisch ein Planet um den Stern herumkreist mit einer relativ hohen Masse, dann führt es dazu, dass sich auch der Stern praktisch auf uns zubewegt und wieder ein bisschen von uns wegbewegt und das in der in der Periodiziertis.
Und das hilft uns dann äh zu bestimmen, was für eine Masse der Planet hat oder überhaupt den Planet ist zu entdecken. Und ähm,
Wenn wir uns äh tatsächlich noch mehr Informationen von dem Planeten haben wollen, also zum Beispiel hat der eine Atmosphäre, woraus besteht die Atmosphäre, dann brauchen wir halt auch ein sehr gutes Signal von der Atmosphäre, um tatsächlich,
bestimmen zu können, was für Moleküle sind in dieser Atmosphäre vorhanden. Und das bedeutet, alles, je näher der Planet an uns dran ist, desto leichter ist es, ihn zu beobachten.
Okay, aber das heißt, alles, alle Planeten, die wir jetzt bisher gefunden haben,
sind auch relativ nah an uns dran. Das war also ein bisschen.
Immer noch relativ dran, ganz genau.
Genau, also wir wir blicken nicht sehr weit ins All, weil würden wir sehr viel weiter blicken, würden wahrscheinlich die Augen, die wir haben, bisher nicht ausreichen.
Dass eben nicht so ist wie Sterne, die wir ja was weiß ich schon bis fast äh an den Urknall ran in irgendeiner Form aufgespürt bekommen diese ganzen Planeten sind halt eigentlich fast nicht zu sehen.
Wir sehen sie nur indirekt, wir sehen sie indirekt über ihre gravitative Wirkung, wir sehen sie indirekt über ihre Verdunkelung von Sternen, so sie denn jetzt sozusagen sich genau zwischen den äh Stern, den sie umkreisen und uns äh dazwischenstellen.
Methode habe ich glaube ich noch vergessen.
Es gibt noch die Methode der direkten Beobachtung.
Ach so ja genau, das ist halt die Frage. Also wie viel könnte man denn schon überhaupt einen direkt sehen? Also.
Das ist tatsächlich auch eine spannende Sache, ähm wenn man ähm sich im Infrarotbereich, im Bereich ähm einen einen Sternenplanetensystem anschaut und den,
das Lichtsignal, das direkt von dem Stern kommt, ausblendet, dann kann man äh die thermische Emission von den Exoplaneten in dem System ebenfalls aufnehmen.
Gibt natürlich einige Probleme. Äh die müssen sehr, sehr heiß sein, damit wir tatsächlich ein Signal bekommen, damit wir tatsächlich im Infrarotbereich die thermische Ausstrahlung haben,
wenn der Planet sehr nah am Stern dran ist, dann wird der genauso mit ausgeblendet, wenn das Licht vom vom Stern ausgeblendet wird.
Es gibt da unterschiedliche Methoden, ähm also das, was ich gerade beschrieben habe, ist, dass man einen sogenannten Honograf baut, also dass man wirklich das Licht direkt von dem Stern ausblendet. Eine andere Variante ist die sogenannte Enterferomatrie.
Wo man ähm tatsächlich aus unterschiedlichen Blickwinkeln das äh System betrachtet und ähm,
praktisch die die Lichtinformation gegenseitig äh auscanceln und dann was tatsächlich übrig bleibt als ähm Lichtquelle ist dann der Planet,
Damit kann man den Planeten sehr gut auch beobachten, sehr nah am Stern dran.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass man damit über unseren Nachbarplaneten ähm in den,
Zum Beispiel im Alpha Zentauri-System oder in anderen Systemen, also Trapis eins ist zum Beispiel auch im Planetensystem, das knapp 40 Lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist, ähm dass man dort tatsächlich die Exoplaneten direkt beobachten kann.
Das äh nennt sich ähm also diese Initiative, die gerade auch in Europa ähm sich damit beschäftigt, nennt sich Live, also Large Interfermator für Exoplanets und hofft in 20, 25 Jahren tatsächlich fliegen zu können und,
so Exoplanet eine direkt zu beobachten.
Ich habe das noch nicht ganz verstanden mit dieser ähm mit dieser Ausblendung des,
Also wie kann man diese Überschneidung hinbekommen. Das heißt, man muss ja aus verschiedenen Positionen schauen. Das das heißt, man muss quasi zwei beobachten, mindestens zwei Beobachtungspunkte haben, die sehr weit voneinander entfernt sind.
Also hier ähm die Idee ist tatsächlich sogar vier relativ weit voneinander entfernte Teleskope im im Weltall zu haben.
Ähm andere Variante ist tatsächlich ähm wenn sie äh wenn der Satellit sich sogar noch dreht ähm,
kann er praktisch mit unterschiedlichen Winkeln ähm das System Stern äh Planetsystem beobachten und auch dann bekommt man unterschiedliche Lichtsignale, die sich dann wieder entsprechend auslöschen können.
Und wo sollen diese Satelliten dann stehen?
Die wären dann im Weltall. Die würden praktisch im Orbit um die Erde sein und zusammen den Flugbratschuss soweit koordinieren, dass sie immer den gleichen Abstand zueinander haben und dementsprechend dann die Beobachtung erlauben.
Die äh Amerikaner hatten doch, haben doch aber auch noch eine Mission. Die Testmission, die äh sich auch auf Exoplaneten stürzt. Richtig?
Genau und ähm Test ist vor einigen Jahren gestartet,
war eigentlich nicht der Gedanke, dass Tess die Auflösung hat auch kleinere Gesteinsplaneten finden zu können, hat aber tatsächlich mittlerweile auch schon,
super Erden finden können, um andere Sterne drumrum und ähm,
tatsächlich war es sogar direkt eine der ersten in den ersten Wochen das Test aktiv war haben sie bereits den ersten äh äh Supererden Exoplaneten gefunden um einen Stern herum,
Auch mit Tests äh können wir äh Planeten finden. Ähm,
Allerdings, wenn wir tatsächlich ähm uns auf die erd großen Planeten oder erd oder möglicherweise erdähnlichen Planeten fokussieren. Dafür brauchen wir eine neue Mission und da ist tatsächlich die Platomission, die 26 starten wird,
der äh große Kandidat dafür viele Planeten ähm von erdroßen Planeten bis Supererden ähm zu finden,
und uns da viel mehr Daten zu liefern und vor allem auch Planeten, die so nah am Stern sind,
ähm die Temperaturen warm genug sind an der Oberfläche das theoretisch flüssiges Wasser möglich wäre, aber nicht so warm, wie es bei der Venus oder bei Merkur zum Beispiel ist, dass das Wasser gar nicht äh sich an der Oberfläche halten kann und,
ähm ist einfach viel zu heiß wird und eine zu starker Treibhauseffekt entsteht.
Soll hatte ich, glaube ich, schon gesagt, 62 äh gestartet werden ist äh Teil dieses Cosmo Vision äh Programms, der äh Esa,
und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also was genau meint man jetzt eigentlich, wenn man von,
erdähnlichen Planeten spricht so. Also.
Wie wie ähnlich meinst du das? Also ähnlich es in genauso wie die Erde oder reicht schon, wenn es ein Steinplanet ist und in etwa die gleiche Größe hat, ist es ist es dann schon eher,
ähnlich, also was sind so die Parameter für diese Ähnlichkeit, an denen man das festmachen kann?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage und tatsächlich, je nachdem, wie man fragt, wird man sicherlich eine andere Antwort.
Gerade jemand der sich mehr mit Atmosphären beschäftigt versteht unter dem erdähnlichen Planet auch tatsächlich einen Planeten der ähm entweder genau die gleiche Atmosphäre hat wie die Erde oder zumindest sehr ähnlich basierend auf CO2, vielleicht Stickstoff,
jemanden, der sich mehr mit dem Inneren vom Planeten beschäftigt, also jemand wie ich,
Da geht's halt eher darum, was sind die, woraus ist der besteht der Planet. Woraus ist er aufgebaut? Was sind die Materialien? Und für mich ist tatsächlich ein er hat ähnlicher Planet auch eher ein Gesteinsplanet.
Wenn man jetzt einen Biologen fragt, ist ein erdähnlicher Planet, ein Planet, der Leben auf der Oberfläche ermöglicht oder sogar erdähnliches Leben hat. Da kommt das erdähnlich auch wieder mit rein. Er hat ähnliches Leben,
Meistens meint man damit äh Kohlenstoff basiertes Leben und jetzt nicht unbedingt Zweibeiner wie wir es sind,
Aber auch da gibt es unterschiedliche Interpretationen. Das Minimale, was man benötigt, um eine zweite Erde zu haben, ist erstmal einen Gesteinsplaneten zu haben.
Mhm. Eisenkern.
Eisenkern oder Metallkern, Silikatmantel, ähm vielleicht auch stärker vermischt als es auf der Erde ist. Das ist wiederum eine andere Frage. Äh wie genau die Materialien separiert sein müssen,
vielleicht mehr Wasser an der Oberfläche, als was auf der Erde haben, vielleicht sogar tiefe Ozeane,
aber generell erstmal die allererste, die minimale Voraussetzung ist, dass es kein Gasplanet ist,
äh die Temperaturen irgendwo an der Oberfläche oder nah an der Oberfläche zum Beispiel ähm wenn wir einen einen einen Planeten haben, der eine Eiskruste und große Wassermengen Untergrund hat,
sind dort immer noch die Temperaturen hoch genug, dass man flüssiges Wasser haben kann. Das ist das, was für mich in ähnlichen Planeten ausmacht.
Magnetfelder, wäre das zwingend.
Tatsächlich der Mars hat kein aktives Magnetfeld und trotzdem würde ich ja als erdähnlichen Planeten bezeichnen.
Mhm.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben bisher noch nicht ausschließen können, dass das Leben auf dem Mars gibt. Ähm wir haben viele Missionen äh auf der Suche nach Leben ähm auf der Oberfläche vom Mars auch jetzt gerade.
Bisher haben wir noch keine Spuren von Leben gefunden, aber wer weiß, im Untergrund vom Maß könnte sich durchaus das eine oder andere Bakterium befinden.
Okay. Also Magnetfeld wäre jetzt nicht erforderlich, obwohl das natürlich sehr hilfreich ist, um sich gegen Strahlen zu schützen.
Direkt an der Oberfläche, wenn man auch gerade wie bei Maas keine dichte Atmosphäre hat, wäre eine Magnetfeld prinzipiell.
Hilfreich. Ähm allerdings ähm reicht auch eine schützende Schicht, wie zum Beispiel, dass man ein paar Meter im Untergrund in der Höhle lebt,
Dann hat man mit der Strahlung auch keine Probleme mehr.
Was weiß man denn jetzt eigentlich und inwiefern.
Betankt das auch noch diese äh Exoplanetenforschung, wie sich jetzt Planeten,
entwickeln, welche Phasen sie jetzt durchmachen, weil er hat ähnlich, also beim Maß geht man ja davon aus, oder ist man sich mittlerweile halt auch sicher, weil die
die Belege stark sind so, da wird es Wasser gegeben haben, da hat's Kanäle äh gegeben, also Flussdeltas et cetera, das findet man ja alles.
Fahren da halt irgendwie Rovas durch und es ist halt ein bisschen trocken so, aber Eis gibt's ja auch. Das sind ja alles so Zyklen, das heißt nicht alles, was,
mal mit einer Atmosphäre unterwegs war, muss zwangsläufig zum Zeitpunkt der Beobachtung dann auch noch so aussehen. Also muss man ja dann sozusagen auch ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, so was was könnte denn mal noch erdähnlicher gewesen.
Sein. Also wie was weiß man über diese Entwicklung der Planeten und inwiefern ist das jetzt äh für deine Arbeit relevant?
Ja, also das ist tatsächlich einer der großen Knackpunkte, wo uns auch die ähm Exotlate sehr viel weiterhelfen, unser eigenes Sonnensystem weiterzuverstehen,
bei uns äh können wir auf den meisten oder sagen wir so auf der Erde oder auf der Venus zum Beispiel können wir nicht besonders weit in die Vergangenheit schauen,
verstehen immer noch nicht besonders gut äh wie sich die Planeten gebildet haben, aus welchem Material sie eigentlich bestehen. Ähm,
hatte man am Anfang einen Planeten, der komplett geschmolzen war, also ein Magma-Ozean nennen wir das, einen globalen oder nur an der Oberfläche. Wie was genau ist eigentlich passiert,
und ähm aufm Mars haben wir zwar ähm ein sehr, sehr viel, viel ältere Oberfläche, die ist dann so um die die vier Milliarden Jahre, etwas älter,
vielleicht sogar, aber die ersten 100 Millionen Jahre, da wissen wir immer noch nicht genau, was passiert eigentlich in dem Planeten? Wie entstehen sie genau? Und was sind vor allem die entscheidenden Faktoren, die entscheiden,
Planet sich so entwickelt wie unsere Erde und später ähm nicht nur flüssiges Wasser an Oberfläche hat, sondern auch Leben bildet,
oder ähm sich so entwickelt, wie sieht der Maß sich entwickelt hat.
Und äh die Beobachtung von Exoplaneten dadurch, dass wir tausende von Exoplaneten mit sehr, sehr unterschiedlichen Altern entdeckt haben und das ist auch wieder was, was jetzt grad diese zukünftigen Missionen noch genauer erforschen werden. Also genau was ist das Alter von Planeten?
Und auch durch die diese Interferometrie und Infrarotmessung von dieser Live-Initiative, von der ich vorhin erzählt hatte. Ähm damit könnte man auch jüngere Planeten unter Umständen beobachten,
vielleicht erst 50, 100 oder 200 Millionen Jahre alt sind. Und das wird uns viel helfen zu verstehen, wie tatsächlich die Entwicklung von diesem Planeten,
geologische Zeitsgeheim funktioniert.
Heißt das, dass man davon ausgeht, dass jetzt alle dass es alle möglichen unterschiedlichen Arten von Entwicklungen gibt oder gibt's schon so ein Standardmodell, wo man sagen kann, so läuft's bei den meisten?
Ich sage mal so, mit jeder neuen Beobachtung lernen wir was Neues dazu. Also das ist einen Standardweg gibt. Ich glaube, äh von der Idee haben sich alle mittlerweile verabschiedet. Ähm,
ob's äh die Bildung ist, äh Sternsystems ist, äh wo die Planeten sich bilden oder wie tatsächlich die Entwicklung von einem Planeten aussieht. Das kann man schon alleine sehen, wenn man sich die unseren Schwesterplaneten Vinus anschaut.
Ist genauso ein Gesteinsplanet wie die Erde, besteht wahrscheinlich aus ziemlich den gleichen Materialien, minimale Unterschiede eventuell,
es etwas näher an der Sonne dran, aber hat über 700 ähm Calvin-Oberflächentemperaturen eine unglaublich dichte CO2-Atmosphäre,
tatsächlich bevor man die Venus ähm durch die Weltraummission besser beobachten konnte, wurde sogar darüber spekuliert, dass die Venus äh bewohnt sein muss von Industrievölkern, die die Atmosphäre völlig mit CO2.
Äh verseucht haben.
Verseucht haben. Äh mittlerweile wissen wir äh, dass es auf der Oberfläche von der Venus definitiv nicht äh die Möglichkeit gibt, äh für Leben, so wie wir's kennen, also Kunststoff basiertes Leben äh zu existieren.
Bei diesen hohen Temperaturen sind die ganzen Kohlenstoffbindungen ähm also alles, was wir brauchen, ob's jetzt DNA ist, ob's Proteine ist, ob's Aminosäuren ist, die sind nicht stabil bei den Temperaturen.
Aber es heißt ja auch nicht, dass diese Temperaturen immer schon so war.
Das ist tatsächlich bei der Venus äh eine riesengroße Fragestellung. Ähm hat die Venus sich verändert über die letzten viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre oder sah sie immer genauso aus, wie sie jetzt aussah?
Ähm dass es eine aktuelle Frage ist, beweist, dass die Esa und die NASA dieses Jahr nicht eine, nicht zwei, sondern drei Venusmissionen ausgewählt haben,
in den nächsten ungefähr zehn Jahren oder in der in den ungefähr zehn Jahren starten sollen,
und ähm zum einen helfen sollen, die äh die Atmosphäre besser zu vermessen, die Oberflächenaktivität zu verstehen, also ob ähm wie wir aktiv Vulkanismus ist zum Beispiel auf der Venus.
Man hofft sich auch Informationen zu finden oder Informationen zu finden darüber, ähm wie die Venus in der Vergangenheit ausgesehen haben könnte. Es,
gibt da tatsächlich unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu, ähm die eine Meinung ist ähm eventuell die Venus sogar sehr ähnlich aus wie die Erde heute. Hatte vielleicht sogar flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche.
Eventuell war aber die Venus immer ein ein höllischer Planet und ähm das herauszufinden wird es auf jeden Fall auch sehr viel helfen.
Mhm. Kommen wir nochmal zurück zu den,
Planeten. Wenn man jetzt so in die Ferne äh schaut und sich jetzt so einen Katalog von ungefähr tausend ist das so die Zahl, die wir derzeit haben, tausend Exoplaneten oder es ist schon höher.
Über viertausend.
Über viertausend. Okay, viertausend haben wir jetzt irgendwie katalogisiert, die sich dann wahrscheinlich auf was weiß ich, drei zweitausend äh Sternsysteme verteilen so.
Ungefähr, genau.
Das war jetzt nur so eine Gefühlseinschätzung so die werden jetzt irgendwie alle beobachtet. Was weiß man denn jetzt,
über diese gesamte Masse von Planeten wie wie viel sind denn jetzt sozusagen erdähnlich? Wie viele sind diese Gasriesen ähm was,
was sagt jetzt erstmal sozusagen der Katalog äh was auf was blicken wir derzeit?
Das ist tatsächlich dann das Traurige daran, also 4000 Exoplaneten klingt natürlich erstmal nach unglaublich vielen Exo,
gar keine Frage. Und äh ungefähr war die die Hälfte mittlerweile ist auch ähm tatsächlich in der Kategorie,
wo wir sagen können, das ist vielleicht eine ein erdähnlicher Planet, eine Supererde, also
eine eine etwas größere ähm schwerere Erde, vielleicht auch ähm eher so eine Art Mini-Naptun, also ein Planet, der sehr sehr hohe Wasservorkommnisse hat.
Das Problem ist dass wir bei vielen entweder nur die Masse oder nur den Radius wissen.
Nur eine Idee von der Masse haben tatsächlich. Die Anzahl der Planeten, wo wir tatsächlich Masse und Radius kennen,
Abstand von der Sonne kreisen, wo man sagt, naja, da könnte flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche existieren. Das sind dann plötzlich nur noch ein paar Handvoll Planeten.
Und ähm das ist genau der Grund, weswegen wir mehr exoplanierten Missionen benötigen, vor allem welche, die wir wirklich gut beobachten können und wo wir dann die Atmosphäre vermessen können und mehr,
lernen können, ist Venus der klassische Exotplanet, ist die Erde der klassische Exotlat, Mars oder vielleicht was ganz anderes.
Paar Hand voll heißt jetzt was, so dreißig, vierzig,
in der Größenordnung. Okay, ist ja jetzt auch erst mal nix. Und wenn man jetzt äh mal schaut, zu was für Sternen die gehören, sind das einfach sind das auch so Singles-Star-Systeme oder dass du so Doppel äh Stern-Systeme, wie verteilt sich das da?
Unterschiedlich, ähm die meisten sind natürlich um um Einzelsterne. Es gibt allerdings auch wirklich ähm interessante Beobachtungen von Exoplaneten, die um Doppelsternsysteme zum Beispiel drum rum gefunden wurden,
Also entweder, dass man zwei Sterne hat, die sich umkreisen und jeder von den beiden Sternen hat jeweils ein eigenes Planetensystem,
oder was ich noch faszinierender finde, zwei Sterne, die sich so eng umkreisen, dass sie tatsächlich einen äußeren Planeten einen dritten Kompanien haben,
und ähm das ist ähm eine eine unglaublich faszinierendes ähm Studienobjekt, auch wenn wir die genau beobachten könnten. Weil diese Planeten natürlich ganz unterschiedlichen äußeren Bedingungen ausgesetzt sind,
innerhalb eines Umlaufs eines Jahres für diesen Planeten sind unglaubliche Temperaturschwankungen zu beobachten,
einfach dadurch, dass sie um zwei Sterne herumkreisen und dementsprechend sehr unterschiedliche Bedingungen ausgesetzt sind.
Auf jeden Fall äh spezielle Sonnenuntergänge, also haben wir schon bei Star Wars gesehen, glaube ich.
Gab's das äh ja auch schon. Von daher muss es wahr sein. Okay, das heißt, man man hat jetzt irgendwie dreißig, vierzig ähm sind und sind diese
Sterne äh dann auch alle in derselben Größenordnung, so dass die dieselbe Art von Sternen oder ist es auch so durch die ganze Klasse von verschiedenen Sonnentypen durchgemischt und durchgewürfelt.
Also man hat Planeten, also von diesen 4000 Planeten, um eigentlich fast jeden Sternentyp mittlerweile bereits gefunden,
die Maße die meisten befinden sich allerdings um kleinere Sterne, sogenannte ähm Em-Zwergsterne.
Und äh der Grund dafür ist ähm diese Sterne sind eh, die am meisten verbreitesten im Universum.
Also ist das für unsere Sonne.
Sonne ist tatsächlich um einiges größer als ein Zwerg. Diese Endsterne äh oder diese Zwergsterne ähm haben sehr eine sehr sehr lange Lebensdauer.
Das heißt, während unsere Sonne zum Beispiel erst viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre alt ist, also im Vergleich zum Universum ähm ist es ein Drittel des Alters vom Universum, also relativ jung noch,
die N-Zwerge, die können halt 10, 20 Milliarden Jahre alt werden. Das heißt, wir haben sehr viele auch ältere Sterne in unserer äh auch in unserer Galaxie.
Und eine andere Sache ist auch, ähm dass man je kleiner der Stern ist, ähm umso leichter kann man einem Planetensignal.
Von dem Stern beobachten, also gerade diese Transitmethode, die wir kurz angesprochen hatten, wo also ein Planet ähm einen Teil des Sterns verdunkelt,
Vorstellt, man hat einen Planeten um eine sehr großen, sehr hellen Stern oder man hat einen Planet im Umlauf um einen sehr, sehr kleinen ähm Stern,
Dann wird natürlich äh je kleiner der Stern ist, desto mehr von der Oberfläche abgedeckt von dem Planeten,
zukommt noch, wenn man sich jetzt für Planeten interessiert, die in dieser habitablen Zone sind, also in diesem Bereich, also eine Habitablationen nennen wir den Bereich, wo flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche möglich sein könnte.
Dann ist es so, dass diese kleinen Sterne viel, viel Licht äh schwacher sind,
dementsprechend dieser Bereich äh der für uns so wahnsinnig interessant ist auf der Suche von der zweiten Erde. Viel näher am Stern dran ist. Das heißt, während man bei einem ähm Stern wie unserer Sonne auch ein Jahr warten müsste, bis man wieder,
Planeten vor dem Stern beobachtet hat,
dauert das bei so diesen kleinen M Stern und Depoximacent Howig zum Beispiel, unser nächster Nachbarstern ist genauso eine. Dauert es vielleicht ein oder zwei Tage,
Das heißt für die Beobachtung und auch für die um um besonders viele Beobachtungsdaten zu finden, was es dann genauere Daten gibt, sind einfach Exoplaneten um diese kleineren Emmsterne sehr viel attraktiver.
Automatisch die Umlaufzeiten schneller sind.
Für Planeten in der habitablen Zone, aber auch generell sind die Planeten ähm näher dran, weil das gesamte System ist praktisch eine Miniaturvariante von unserem Sonnensystem.
Das kann man zum Beispiel sehen äh bei dem einen Planetensystem, das hatten wir vorhin schon angesprochen, das Trapis eins-System, was knapp 40 Lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist. Dort gibt es sieben Exoplaneten,
äh unglaublich nahe um den Stern herumkreisen und ähm der erste ähm hat eine Umlaufbahn von ähm,
ungefähr ein eineinhalb Tagen und der am weitesten entfernte Planet äh hat immer noch nur eine Umlaufperiode von zwanzig Tagen,
Das heißt, wenn man das äh vergleicht mit unserem Sonnensystem, äh liegt das gesamte Planetensystem von Trapis eins innerhalb von der Umlaufbahn von Merkur um unsere Sonne.
Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es dort zwei oder drei Planeten, die eventuell flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche haben können.
Was los. Gehen wir doch mal auf auf Trappist, Trapist war ja eine eine eine riesige Entdeckung. Insofern, als dass da so viele Planeten sind und,
schon grad erwähnt haben, sehr viele auch eben potenziell in dieser habitablen Zone sind. Trotzdem ist das alles nur so ein
so ein mini äh Mini-Kosmos in gewisser Hinsicht, wo ja alles äh schön nah beieinander ist, wurde glaube ich zwanzig sechzehn erste Mal äh entdeckt und dann im nächsten Jahr wusste man, aha okay, da sind jetzt nochmal sehr viel mehr.
Planeten, also es sind dann insgesamt sieben, wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Genau. Und der erste Planet ist äh Trapis eins B. Das ist meine sehr, sehr komische ähm,
Art und Weise wie in der Astronomie die äh Benennung von ähm Stern und dem Planetensystem ist. A ist praktisch der erste Körper, ist der Stern selber und ab B werden die Planeten praktisch äh durchnummeriert, sage ich.
Ein Doppelstellensystem ist.
Dann sind die Sterne nochmal unterschiedlich mit Großbuchstaben A und B und da werden da unterschieden, aber die Kleinstplaneten, um praktisch einen von den Sternen, wenn dann weiter mit den Buchstaben ähm na, ich sage mal, durchnummeriert.
Ja. Mhm.
Und bei äh Trabbi's äh eins äh die der nächste Planet, also Trapis eins B ähm der hat wie gesagt nur eine Umlaufbahn von anderthalb Tagen hat,
hat ähm entsprechend auch äh bekommt ihr sehr viel Wärme von der Sonne ab, also tatsächlich ungefähr viermal so viel wie die Erde von unserer Sonne ab.
Und das bedeutet für den Planeten, das ist wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr heiß ist an der Oberfläche. Das könnte also direkt schon eine Art Venus ähm.
Oder Venus Cousin sein.
Könnte auch ähnlich wie bei Merkur sein was für mich der große Unterschied zwischen Venus und Merkur ist, ist die Frage, gibt es eine Atmosphäre oder gibt es keine Atmosphäre,
Und äh bei den Trapisplaneten ist man jetzt tatsächlich schon auf der Suche und versucht nachzuvollziehen, woraus die Atmosphäre besteht,
und äh man man konnte schon ausschließen, dass es sich um eine Wasserstoffatmosphäre zum Beispiel handelt. Man weiß aber nicht, ob es äh ob die Planeten eine Atmosphäre wie die Venus, also ein CO2 dominierte Atmosphäre haben kann. Das ist durchaus möglich.
Oder wie beim Merkur. Mehr oder weniger keine Luft zum Atmen an der Oberfläche wäre.
40 Lichtjahre ist das entfernt. Wie kann man da auf eine Atmosphäre schauen?
Also was genau, welche Beobachtungsmethode gibt einem Informationen da drüber, wie eine, also ob es eine Atmosphäre gibt und woraus sie bestehen könnte. Da muss man ja den ja schon richtig gut sehen und um da so eine spektrale Auswertung machen zu können.
Also wenn man versuchen würde, diese Planeten direkt zu beobachten, dann ist es sicherlich äh etwas schwieriger, dann ist es am am Limit von dem, was wir machen können,
es gibt eine interessante andere Variante das Licht von dem Stern bei 40 Lichtjahren können wir relativ leicht einfangen,
Man kann das Spektrum von einem Stern beobachten, genauso wie wir's in der Schule gemacht haben, weil das was Spektrum von der Sonne uns angeschaut haben,
dann in dem Spektrum dieses schwarzen Obsortionslinien haben, die uns anzeigen, ähm was für ein Licht praktisch ähm oder was für Moleküle das Licht ähm filtern auf dem Weg von der Sonne zu uns.
Und äh genauso kann man das bei dem ähm bei jedem beliebigen Stern ebenfalls die Spektrallinien messen, das Spektrum messen und ähm sieht erstmal nur, woraus praktisch der Stern selber besteht oder die Atmosphäre von dem Stern.
Aber ein Planet, der eine Atmosphäre hat, äh direkt vor dem Stern der Umlaufbahn zieht.
Leuchtet ja praktisch das Licht von dem Stern durch die Atmosphäre vom Planeten.
Durch und dann bildet man die Differenz sozusagen.
Ganz genau.
Messung.
Man kann sich jetzt natürlich auch vorstellen, dass der Fehlerbalken dort relativ enorm ist,
Deswegen ist halt die direkte Beobachtung von dem Exoplaneten, wo man wirklich nur das äh Licht, das thermische äh Emission von einem direkt beobachten Licht äh aufnimmt, natürlich noch attraktiver.
Mhm. Was wäre denn, wenn jetzt so ein ähm sagen wir mal der erste Planet in so einem schnellen System,
jetzt gar keine Atmosphäre. Wäre halt einfach nur so ein knalliger Steinkörper, wo irgendwie nichts passiert. So Merkur Style,
Würde man denn überhaupt noch bei diesem Transit eine Änderung der Spitralien entdecken oder könnte man dann genau sagen, so ja nee, der einfach mal nüscht.
Also ich gebe mal ein anderes Beispiel von einem Planeten, der noch näher an seinem Stern kreist. Ähm,
nennt der sich. Ähm das ist auch in den äh Exot in den äh Doppelsternsystem.
Geht auch locker von der Zunge, würde ich sagen.
Ähm ein paar Mal geübt, dann geht das ganz schnell, ganz genau. Und ähm der ist tatsächlich äh über über tausend. Also das heißt, da sind Oberflächentemperaturen, da hat man keine normale Atmosphäre mehr, wie wir es jetzt bei der Erde uns vorstellen.
Aber da kann man tatsächlich so eine Art Silikat-Atmosphäre messen, also man man kommt oder auch bei anderen Planeten, die so extrem heiß sind, weil sie so nah an ihrem Sternen dran sind,
äh verflüchtigt sich teilweise das Gestein in die Atmosphäre.
Äh da kann man tatsächlich ähm viel messen, aber es ist halt keine Atmosphäre, wie wir sie kennen. Es hat nichts mit ähm.
Also ist nur die nur die Vergasung der der der des Steinkörpers, aber der lässt sich dann als solcher auch sehen. Das,
sieht schon eine Änderung im Spektrum, aber man weiß, aha, okay, aber das ist jetzt nicht jetzt so das Gas, wie wir uns das jetzt vorstellen und es ist mehr eine Ausgasung und nicht zu sehr eine Atmosphäre. So, aber wenn jetzt ähm,
Die anderen Trappisten äh ankommen und die haben jetzt offensichtlich eine Atmosphäre, dann oder weiß man noch nicht.
Das weiß man noch nicht.
Weiß man noch nicht, aber das will man sozusagen machen.
Man könnte es eventuell äh ab dem nächsten Jahr herausfinden äh mit einem neuen Weltraumteleskop, was Ende diesen Jahres starten wird.
Heißt das, dass das jetzt bisher noch mit gar keinem Teleskop möglich war und das so noch nie getan wurde oder gab's schon mal einen Teleskop, wo diese Methode auch äh probiert wurde.
Also das Problem ist, es hängt halt ab äh von der Art der Atmosphäre, wie leicht sie beobachbar ist,
Das heißt, man konnte mit äh Beobachtungsmethoden, die man jetzt schon zur Verfügung hatte, gewisse Atmosphären ausschließen. Also wie jetzt zum Beispiel eine wasserstoffreiche Atmosphäre.
Was wir sagen Atmosphäre wäre, das konnte man bereits ausschließen. Ein anderes Problem ist wenn die gesamte Atmosphäre wolkenverhangen ist, auch dann,
ist es sehr sehr schwierig überhaupt ähm ein Spektrum zu bekommen, aus dem man ähm in einer Atmosphäre herauslesen kann. Das heißt, es hängt auch sehr von der Atmosphäre, von den Planeten ab,
was man tatsächlich messen kann und wie gut man die Atmosphäre bestimmen kann,
Es gibt ähm Atmosphären von Exoplaneten, die jetzt nicht mehr diese er hat ähnlichen Planeten, Gescheinsplaneten sind,
indem man tatsächlich auch zum Beispiel Wasser schon entdeckt hat und ähm unterschiedliche Komponenten, Kohlenstoff, äh Gase entdeckt hat. Das heißt, äh je nachdem wie gesagt, das hängt immer von dem Planetensystem direkt ab,
leicht die Atmosphäre beobachtbar ist. Und ähm da hilft es natürlich, wenn wir vorher verstehen,
oder versuchen zu verstehen, ähm bei welchen Exponeten würden wir eher erwarten, dass wir eine Atmosphäre haben, die wir auch messen können oder dass es überhaupt eine Atmosphäre gibt und äh nicht ein Merkur ähnlichen Planeten?
Und äh dafür braucht man tatsächlich äh nomerische Modelle, die versuchen basierend auf dem Wissen, was wir in unserem Sonnensystem haben.
Wollen wir wissen, wie Atmosphären funktionieren, wie auch das Innere von dem Planet mit der Atmosphäre gekoppelt ist, zum Beispiel durch vulkanische Ausgasung,
dass wir dadurch verstehen wie über lange Zeit sich ein Planet entwickelt und wo es am wahrscheinlichsten wir eine Atmosphäre zu haben, die wir dann auch tatsächlich messen können.
Also wie ich das richtig verstehe man kann jetzt äh mit dem derzeitigen Instrumentarium bestenfalls bei manchen Exoplaneten,
bestimmte Dinge ausschließen, wie äh wie die Atmosphäre ist, aber man ist noch nicht in der Lage mit dem derzeitigen Besteck
konkret zu sagen, hier haben wir einen Exoplaneten und wir haben uns den so gut anschauen können, dass wir genau wissen, woraus die Atmosphäre besteht. Da sind wir noch nicht.
Also bei erdroßen Planeten, nein.
Okay, bei Erdgroß, aber bei den bei den Gasries.
Wenn man je größer der Planet ist, genau da wurden auch mehrere Gase schon äh besser äh bestimmt.
Heißt okay, also die Methode existiert, ist da, aber sie ist noch nicht anwendbar auf.
Genauigkeit ist noch.
Die erdähnlichen Planeten, auf die wir bei uns ja jetzt hier grade beschäftigen. Aber um dem näher zu kommen, gibt's diesen anderen Ansatz und das ist ja im Wesentlichen so dein mathematische Ansatz,
hier äh quasi die ganze Entwicklung des Planeten in so ein großes Modell reinzustecken und zu sagen, was wir nicht beobachten können, das können wir einfach ausrechnen.
Oder andersrum ähm praktisch die Kandidaten herauszuwählen, wo man am ehesten was beobachten kann.
Und wenn es so das jetzt auch konkret auf Trappist eins schon an.
Genau, also Trapis eins ist natürlich in den äh System, was äh viele Modellierer derzeit unglaublich begeistert. Dadurch, dass es halt so viele unterschiedliche Planeten gibt, äh die teilweise extrem heiß an der Oberfläche sind, teilweise extrem kalt an der Oberfläche.
Aber die alle ja Steinplaneten sind und die alle auch erdross sind.
Genau, die sind alle erdroß ungefähr, aber die äußersten Planeten haben eine Dichte, die ein bisschen niedriger ist als bei der Erde. Und das heißt, dort würde man davon ausgehen, dass man sehr große Wasser oder vielleicht sogar Eismassen hat.
Das ist ganz spannend, weil das haben wir in unserem Sonnensystem. Wir haben zwar die Eismonde, aber wir haben jetzt nicht ähm Eisplaneten in dem Sinne.
Und das Spannende ist halt bei dem Trapissystem, ähm dass das Material trotzdem relativ ähnlich ist, also die Zusammensetzung von dem Planeten relativ ähnlich ist.
Außer natürlich dann tatsächlich der Wasseranteil oder der der Anteil von leichtem Material, der sehr stark schwankt in dem Planetensystem.
Und das heißt hier können wir äh relativ gut versuchen nachzuvollziehen, woran liegt das? Oder auch bei den Planeten, die relativ nah am Stern dran sind. Wie wären die tatsächlich aufgeheizt?
Also nicht nur von der Oberfläche her, von der Sonnenstrahlung her, sondern auch, was passiert im Inneren, ähm wie viel Wärme wird im Inneren produziert,
ähm vor allem zum Beispiel durch Gezeiten, Kräfte, wie man's ja vom Mond kennt, dass der Mond die ähm Blut und Ebbe auf der Erde beeinflusst,
Genauso beeinflusst die Erde auch tatsächlich die Wärmeproduktion im Mond durch die gleichen Kräfte,
das sieht man auch in unserem Sonnensystem ganz schön bei dem Jupiter Mond äh,
tatsächlich von äh also anderen Planeten im Jupitersystem und dem Jupiter selber so hin und her gedrückt und gequetscht wird, ähm dass der im Inneren teilweise sogar geschmolzen ist, soweit wir wissen.
Ist nicht nur äh Ayo, sondern es betrifft ja im Prinzip alle Galiläschen, Mode, hatten wir bloß hier in der letzten äh Sendung ein Gespräch über die Juice-Mission, die ja im Prinzip genau das auch aus äh messen soll, wie sehr die äh Monde zusammengequetscht werden.
Nochmal bei Trapist eins und äh auch diese numerische äh aus ähm Wertung. Also man will ja jetzt irgendwie herausfinden, okay,
Was geht da? Man hat jetzt sehr sehr beschränkte Daten, aber die kann man natürlich in so ein Modell reintun. Was genau also was,
das mal beschreiben, wie man
an so ein Modell rangeht, was was steckt man da rein, was sind da so quasi die die die Variablen und was was kann man dann tatsächlich daraus
gewinnen, also welche Informationen fallen da raus, was muss man reinstecken, was fällt raus und welchen Erkenntnisgewinn kann man damit äh sich anbahnen lassen.
Also was äh noch ganz wichtig ist bei vielen äh Planetensystemen haben wir sehr gute Informationen über den Stern, über das Spektrum von dem.
Und äh das gibt uns eine wichtige Information. Denn wir wissen, dass die Sterne mit ihrem Planeten zusammen aus einer Wolke entstehen,
bedeutet das Material, dass wir einen Planeten finden, ähm hängt direkt mit der Zusammensetzung von dem Stern zusammen.
Aber das ist ja alles eine große Staubwolke. Daraus bildet sich äh der oder die Sonne. Und aus dem Rest werden die Planeten gemacht in dieser Aggressionsscheibe, findet sich das immer. Das Modell sieht man überall im Weltall.
Ganz genau, ganz genau und äh die Sterne bestehen natürlich hauptsächlich auf so was wie Wasserstoff und Hejung, haben aber einen ganz kleinen Bruchteil von diesen schwereren Elementen,
Diese schweren Elemente und äh auch größtenteils in der Zusammensetzung, wie wir sie im Stern tatsächlich haben. Davon gehen wir davon aus, dass wir die auch in dem gleichen Verhältnis zumindest in Gesteinsplaneten haben, die sich nahe an der Umgebung vom Stern bilden.
Sehen wir bei dem im Sonnensystem ähm passt das relativ gut ähm dass die Zusammensetzung von der Erde sich relativ gut,
vergleichen lässt mit dem Spektrum von dem Stern, wenn man ähm betrachtet, wie tatsächlich diese Planeten entstehen durch Kondensation von von Staubpart.
Also alles, was in der Erde ist, findet sich im Prinzip auch in der Sonne.
Genau und fast im gleichen Zusammenhang, aber wir verstehen auch, warum der äh das kein Eins-zu-Eins-Verhältnis ist.
Wenn man das jetzt auf andere Systeme übertragen, können wir damit, wenn wir das Sternspektrum relativ gut beobachten können und wissen, woraus der Stern entsteht, gibt uns das Informationen, was sind tatsächlich die Bausteine von dem Planeten.
Und Trappes eins A, also die Sonne können wir gut beobachten.
Trappist äh eins haben wir Informationen dazu.
Meine ist ja relativ nah dran. Vierzig Liedjahre ist ja quasi nix, ist ja quasi vor Ort und das müsste ja nun wirklich schon sehr gut vorliegen. Das heißt, das ist schon mal erstmal die Kerninformation, die in dieses Modell einfließt.
Ganz genau und das äh gibt uns halt eine Information, äh woraus diese Planeten bestehen müssten. Das Spannende ist dann daran, dass die Materialien selber ähm sind zwar nicht im gleichen Verhältnis vorhanden, wie wir's jetzt bei uns in der Erde zum Beispiel haben.
Aber die Mineralologie, die sich daraus bildet, also praktisch die einzelnen Minerale, die sich praktisch bei denen entsprechenden Temperaturen, bei den entsprechenden Abständen von Trapis eins äh bilden. Die entsprechend auch Mineralien, die wir auf der Erde haben.
Das bedeutet, da haben wir relativ gute Kenntnisse, wie diese Minerale sich auf die unterschiedlichen Temperaturen, unterschiedlichen Drücken verhalten,
Und ähm damit können wir praktisch herleiten.
Moin, sind die Minerale ist das Wissen um diese Minerale ein Ergebnis der Simulation oder ein Ergebnis der Beobachtung?
Von experimentellen Daten tatsächlich. Also wir wissen auf der Erde die die Hauptkomponenten woraus die Erde besteht,
können im Labor dann die Eigenschaften von den unterschiedlichen Mineralen, von dem Gestein, von der Erde nachvollziehen.
Durchmessungen von Laborexperimenten.
Ähm diese Information hilft uns dann sehr zu verstehen, ähm wie grundlegende Eigenschaften in diesen Exoplaneten aussehen sollten und ähm eine von den wichtigsten ist zum Beispiel die Wärmeleitfähigkeit.
Planeten, wenn die sich bilden, sind unglaublich heiß und sie kühlen über Milliarden von Jahren aus.
Je nachdem, wie gut sie auskühlen können ähm für das äh zu entweder zu einem maßähnlichen Körper, der an der Oberfläche relativ äh langweilig aussieht. Und ich hoffe, dass mir meine Kollegen vom DLR das jetzt gerade nicht übel nehmen.
Alles relativ.
Ähm gegenüber einem Planeten wie äh Erde, die dann halt Plattentektonik hat, Vulkanismus hat. Und das hängt alles damit zusammen, wie stark oder wie gut der Planet küren kann, wie sehr die Wärme tatsächlich,
äh einfach durch Leitfähigkeit ähm durch den Mantel transportiert werden kann vom Innersten bis zur Oberfläche.
Oder wenn's halt nicht effektiv passiert, dann passiert es dazu, dass Gestein äh wieder aufschmilzt,
die Temperaturen, bei denen das passiert, auch das können wir wieder berechnen, basierend aus der Zusammensetzung, die wir halt denken, die diesen Planeten haben.
Und ähm das hilft uns zu verstehen, ob es äh bei diesem Planeten, ob sie im Inneren geschmolzen sein müssten oder nicht.
Also verstehe ich das richtig? Wir gehen jetzt im Prinzip erst mal ausschließlich starten wir mit dem Spektrum,
Also der Zusammensetzung der Sonne, wir wissen die Masse und so weiter und äh dauert ergeben sich halt äh viele Sachen und das,
dann geht man im Prinzip zurück in der Zeit und sagt, okay, alles klar, wenn da jetzt diese Bestandteile drin sind, dann bedeutet das die da muss eine Stoppwolke gegeben haben, die hat jetzt irgendwie,
die und die,
Masse äh gehabt, daraus sind was weiß ich, vielleicht 99 Prozent in der Sonne davon äh gelandet und dann hat sich aus dieser Aggretionsscheibe haben sich die Planeten gebildet. Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt, also schon aus diesem nah, also das Modell versucht quasi,
Geschichte nachzuvollziehen, der kompletten Entstehung dieses Sonnensystems, ja und der äh Ausbildung dieser Planeten.
Wobei dann wahrscheinlich die real beobachtete Zahl von Planeten auch ein weiterer Parameter ist. Also man weiß einfach, die sind dabei rausgekommen oder,
Lässt man das eigentlich weg und tuned sein Modell so, dass dann diese Zahl von Planeten auch bei rauskommt und dann weiß man, dadurch ist es richtig.
Ist das mehr so ein Korrekturfaktor oder das ist mehr so ein so ein Eingabewert.
Also es gibt auch äh Modelierer, die sich tatsächlich mit dieser Frage beschäftigen, wie viele Planeten genau bilden sich, in welchem Orbit, in welchem Abstand äh von dem Stern,
und äh die auch versuchen nachzuvollziehen, warum unser Sonnensystem exakt so aussieht, wie er aussieht mit dem Astroidengürtel zwischen Maß und Jupiter und diese Spaltung im inneren äußeren Sonnensystem,
Für mich ist es eher spannend zu schauen, welche Temperaturen haben in einem bestimmten Abstand von einem Stern geherrscht, wo wir jetzt den Planeten finden,
eventuell der Planet sich auch etwas bewegt, aber gerade bei diesem Trapis eins-System geht man davon aus, dass die Planeten sich nicht zu weit weg vom Stern gebildet haben, relativ wenig dort, wo sie jetzt auch grade sind.
Und äh wir können dann nachvollziehen, wie sich praktisch die Temperaturen in dieser Aggressionsscheibe verändert haben.
Heißt für jemanden, der sich jetzt die Zusammensetzung von diesen Exoplaneten äh versucht äh aus dem Sternspektrum herauszuleiten, geht's nicht mehr darum,
ob sich Planeten bilden oder wie sich Planeten bilden könnten, also die die Dynamik in dieser Aggressionsscheibe von der Planetenbildung ist weniger wichtig, sondern eher der Temperaturverlauf,
welches Material an der Stelle, wo der Planet sich befindet oder gefunden haben kann in der Vergangenheit, nacheinander auskondensiert, aus dieser Aggressionsscheibe.
Also um man versucht das da zu vollziehen, um dann herauszufinden oder eine Annahme darüber zu machen, woraus könnte jetzt der Planet an dieser Position bestehen.
In Folge der Temperaturverteilung, die letzten Endes dann eben auch eine Aussage darüber treffen lässt, was quasi jetzt aus dem zur Verfügung stehenden Material gebacken wird.
Salopp,
gesagt. So, das heißt, man äh versucht quasi so ein bisschen das Rezept zu bestimmen, mit dem jeder äh einzelne dieser Planeten so zusammengesetzt ist, auch wenn sie im Prinzip alle äh
aus denselben Grundstoffen hervorgehen, dürften die inneren ja nochmal etwas schwerere Komponenten haben und die äußeren, die etwas leichteren.
Aber vor allem sind sie alle mit unterschiedlichen Temperaturen konfrontiert, woraus sich dann eben andere Mineralverbindungen bilden und deswegen so und das heißt dann spielen wir das Spiel so weiter, die Simulation äh versucht dann die ganze Entstehungsgeschichte
jedes einzelnen Planeten nachzuvollziehen.
Ganz genau und da ist es auch ganz wichtig, dass ähm die die Oberflächentemperatur spielt da natürlich auch wieder eine Rolle.
Die es beeinflusst davon, ob man zum Beispiel eine dichte Atmosphäre hat, wieder bei der Venus oder eine kalte Temperatur hat wie beim Mars,
Also das das ist ein ganz wichtiger Faktor und das heißt, die die Idealvorstellung von allen, die sich äh mit diesem Themenkomplex beschäftigen, ist ähm dass eine super Modell zu haben, wo tatsächlich auch die Atmosphärenentwicklung,
sehr gut mit der mit der Sternstrahlung gekoppelt wird, dass man genau versteht, wie sich die Atmosphäre über lange Zeitsgeile halten kann,
Gerade bei diesen Emmstern ähm geht man davon aus, äh dass die Aktivität von dem von den Sternen sehr stark ist und dass äh sie super Winderuptionen haben, die praktisch den
Atmosphären in bei Planeten, die relativ nah am Sternen sind, kaum eine Überlebungschancen geben.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen der kritische Punkt, ähm dass man sich so stark auf diese Exoplaneten, um diese elf Sterne konzentriert,
man weiß tatsächlich gar nicht, ähm wie oder wie stark Atmosphären bei diesem Planeten tatsächlich überleben können.
Das ist halt natürlich eine ganz wichtige Randbedingung wiederum für Modellierung, die sich im Inneren damit beschäftigen, wie äh der Wärmetransport ist, wie die chemische Entwicklung auch im Inneren stattfindet, ob's auch Vökanismus gibt oder Ähnliches.
Ist direkt damit gekoppelt, was hat sich an der Oberfläche passiert.
Und da weiß ich,
eine ganze Menge schiefgehen. Insbesondere bei solchen Modellen und Simulationen, meine äh das ist ja so ein bisschen so, als ob man jetzt äh quasi so Billardstöße nicht nur die nächsten fünf, sondern irgendwie so die nächsten fünf
Milliarden Billiardstöße äh ausrechnen möchte und wenn man halt irgendwie schon beim Ersten da so eine geringe Abweichung von 0, 0001 Grad gehabt hat, dann,
passt am Ende halt überhaupt nix mehr. Wie geht man mit sowas um? Ich meine, stelle mir das jetzt grade so vor,
erstmal Wasser alles mit reinfließen muss, abgesehen von korrekten Parametern und Informationen den richtigen Algorithmen. Natürlich ist ja auch, dass man eigentlich in solche Simulationen,
vollständige physikalische Wissen, auch das geologische Verhalten der Materie, Temperatur, wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen, all diese ganzen Parametervergasungen, Termodynamik, Pipapo ist ja alles drin.
Woher weiß man denn, dass die so ein Modell,
überhaupt brauchbare Informationen liefert oder wie kalibriert man so ein Modell, dass man zumindest so ein Gefühl dafür hat, dass es halbwegs stimmen könnte.
Ich würde sagen, es gibt äh drei Probleme bei solchen Modellen. Ähm das erste Problem ist, dass ähm wir immer mit irgendwas beginnen müssen.
Egal ob ihr uns den Planeten genau anschauen wie er heute ist oder wir versuchen zu verstehen wirklich von der Planetenbildung bis heute wie sich im Planeten entwickelt hat. Äh Anfangstemperaturen äh die Zusammensetzung. Es gibt einfach Informationen, die wir nicht genau kennen.
Das ist das erste Problem. Das zweite Problem ist, dass wir auch die Computersimulation durchführen müssen. Das bedeutet, wenn wir alles zu 100 Prozent genau machen und eine Auflösung nehmen, die genau unser Traumauflösung,
Sein Computermodell entspricht, müssen wir auch tausend Jahre warten, bis die Ergebnisse da sind. Das heißt, wir müssen vereinfachen an bestimmten Stellen. Das ist das zweite Problem.
Und das dritte Problem ist natürlich, dass wir basierend auf dem Wissen arbeiten, dass wir bisher haben, von der Physik, von von der von der Geologie, von unterschiedlichen Prozessen,
wir haben und auch die entwickelt sich natürlich Stück für Stück weiter. Je mehr wir entdecken, desto mehr ähm lernen wir auch mit dazu,
Und was machen wir also, um um das zu umgehen? Das das Dritte, also die Kalibrierung, äh äh die du grad schon genannt hattest, ähm das ist natürlich ein ähm dafür aus unser Sonnensystem perfekt geeignet.
Also gerade mit den Modellen, die wir haben, können wir sehr gut oder relativ gut nachvollziehen, warum Maas genauso aussieht, wie er heute aussieht. Warum die Venus so aussieht, wie sie aussieht.
Was heißt relativ gut?
Relativ gut heißt, äh es kommt immer auf die Detail,
Genauigkeit natürlich an, aber es ist relativ einfach zu verstehen, warum der Mars keine Plattentektonik hat. Warum der Mars,
keinen aktiven Vokanismus hat, obwohl es vielleicht mal ab und zu mal einen kleinen Vulkanausbruch geben kann, aber das können wir sehr gut nachvollziehen. Warum der Mars auch keine dichte Atmosphäre mehr hat.
Venus genau das Gleiche. Wir verstehen äh relativ gut, warum wir diesen Treibhauseffekt haben auf der Venus.
Gesagt, wir wissen nicht, wie's früher auf der Venus ausgesehen hat, weil da tatsächlich unterschiedliche Modelle jeweils zu gleichen Venus heute,
führen. Und deswegen ist es relativ schwer, dass ähm die in die Vergangenheit zu schauen bei der Venus zumindest. Aber da werden uns die Missionen hoffentlich weiterhelfen.
Ja. Das heißt, man kann so ein Modell an unserem Sonnensystem quasi kalibrieren und immer wieder überprüfen, so nach dem Motto
wenn wenn mit dem Modell, wie wir's jetzt gerade programmiert haben und den Daten, die wir da reingepackt haben, aus äh
Zusammensetzung unseres Sonnensystems nicht am Ende irgendwie ein korrekter Maß eine korrekte Venus und eine korrekte Erde bei rauskommen so dann äh hat man die physikalische Realität äh verpasst.
Genau und auch für diesen Zusammenhang zwischen der Sternenzusammensetzung und dem Planetenzusammensetzung,
auch mittlerweile mehrere Arbeiten, die halt auch die Exoplanetendaten, wo wir die Dichte relativ gut bestimmen konnten von dem Planeten, auch auf die Zusammensetzung von den Planeten zurückgeführt haben, dass auch da dieser Zusammenhang zwischen Stern und Planet
relativ gut bestimmt wurde,
das andere Problem betrifft, ähm dass wir vereinfachen müssen, da gibt's wiederum Untersuchungen, die halt genau schauen, welche Vereinfachung dürfen wir machen und welche Vereinfachung nicht.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns also grade was aus einer Auflösung von einem Modell betrifft, können wir relativ gut für einzelne Simulationen schauen.
Wo dürfen wir einen Schritt zurückgehen und das ein bisschen gröber betrachten und wo nicht.
Die erste Sache, also woher wissen wir eigentlich die genauen Randbedingungen, die Anfangsbedingungen von solchen Simulationen,
Da ist es tatsächlich der Ansatz bei vielen so und so mache ich das auch, dass wir dort zufällige Werte nutzen. Das heißt, all diese Daten, die wir nicht kennen,
in einem bestimmten Bereich, der teilweise auch durch Beobachtung gegeben ist oder durch Experimente begeben ist. Die werden zufällig gewählt und dann,
schauen wir uns nicht die Entwicklung von Trapis 1 B in einer Simulation an, sondern in tausend. Das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass wir sehr viel Rechenkapazität benötigen,
Wenn wir dann allerdings merken, entweder völlig unabhängig davon, was die Anfangsbedingungen sind, bekommen wir immer das gleiche Ergebnis raus.
Dann wüssten wir oder haben wir ein sehr gutes statistisches Verständnis dafür, wie sich der Planet entwickeln sollte.
Oder wir merken genau dieser Parameter, ist der Keeperameter, der beeinflusst, ob,
zu einem Planet wie die Erde entwickelt oder Maß entwickelt oder Venus entwickelt, dann hilft es uns zu verstehen, welche Parameter wir in der Zukunft besser verstehen müssen.
Also was bei zukünftigen Missionen stärker beobachtet werden soll.
Entweder Beobachtung oder auch tatsächlich Labordaten auf der Erde, die wir generieren können,
Also grade ähm was tief in der Erde passiert und auch tief in dem äh Exoplaneten passiert, ähm sind teilweise Vorgänge, die wir in Hochdruckexperimenten,
bestimmen könnten.
Und das hilft dann tatsächlich äh zu verstehen, was sind die wichtigen Parameter und welche haben im Endeffekt für die Langzeitentwicklung von dem Planeten gar keinen großen Einflus.
Ist das jetzt so ein äh so dieses Software? Ist das ist das jetzt so ein Modell, was das nur so bei euch in der FU gibt und das ist so euer privates Ding oder entwickelt man so was äh dann auch schon open source global und lässt äh viele andere dann teilhaben, weil ich meine, man programmiert ja jetzt nicht jeden Tag äh
mal eben so eine Sonnensystemsimulation äh komplett neu und da macht's auch eigentlich sehr viel mehr Sinn,
Mit der gesamten Community zu arbeiten, gibt's da jetzt so ein etabliertes System, was,
alle sich teilen oder gibt's so verschiedene, die miteinander konkurrieren und äh alle versuchen, irgendwie das Beste rauszubekommen oder macht da muckelt da jeder an seinem eigenen Ding.
Es gibt vor allem viel zusammenarbeiten. Also es gibt glaube ich nicht jemanden, der den gesamten Code von Anfang, von der Sternentstehung bis zu späteren Planetenentwicklung modellieren kann, aber man arbeitet dann mit den äh Fachexperten zusammen, die halt unterschiedliche Abschnitte,
bei der Entstehung von Planeten und der Langzeitentwicklung vom Planeten dann miteinander äh dass man das miteinander kombinieren,
Es gibt natürlich mehrere Modelle, ähm die entwickelt wurden, um zum Beispiel diese in Planeteninneren zu verstehen.
Ähm das finde ich allerdings auch wichtig, denn wenn's nur ein einziges Modell gibt und da ein Fehler existiert,
Leidet die gesamte Community darunter. Ähm was wir tatsächlich haben, wir entwickeln ähnliche Modelle mit einem unterschiedlichen Fokus,
je nachdem was die wissenschaftliche Hauptfragestellung ist, die unterschiedliche Arbeitsgruppen dann beschäftigt. Es gibt auch tatsächlich Open Source Codes, die dann auch weiterentwickelt werden von der Community. Das Wichtige ist aber, dass wir regelmäßig die Codes miteinander vergleichen.
Dass wir dadurch sichergehen, dass alle genau das machen, was sie machen sollen. Also nicht nur an Planeten, Entwicklungsmodellen vergleichen,
tatsächlich den Mars und die Venus zum Beispiel nachvollziehen können, sondern auch zu schauen, ob die Codes tatsächlich genau das gleiche ergeben, wenn wir genau die gleichen Input und Randbedingungen geben.
Äh das ist äh was ganz Wichtiges und das erfordert eine Zusammenarbeit von der Community, die aber zum Glück äh überall gegeben ist.
Mhm. Was heißt, das ist so eine richtig große Modelliererszene, die im Prinzip genauso arbeitet. Man ist ja,
Prinzip die Anforderungen von moderner Software äh Entwicklung heutzutage auch, dass man so testbasiert arbeitet, dass man irgendwie äh immer wieder versucht so Fehler auch äh
zu finden, indem man eben Ergebnisse vergleicht
in dem Moment, wo man sich eben jetzt auch nicht unbedingt auf ein System verlassen will, würde es ja zumindest auch schon mal helfen.
So modularen Ansatz zu machen, so nach dem Motto man kann so verschiedene
Mantelkonvention. Da reinpluggen und im Hintergrund läuft halt quasi das Modell immer wieder durch und heute nehmen wir mal das. Heute nehmen wir mal das und gucken wir mal, was die so einzeln heraus
bringen, so einfach, um da so ein, so einen permanenten Softwarefortschritt auch zu haben und sie auch sicher äh sein zu können, dass man einerseits auf verschiedenste Module jederzeit zugreifen kann, um
quasi mit einem anderen Ansatz äh mal wieder so ein Modell auszuprobieren und andererseits eben nicht in diese Falle zu treten, dass man sagt so ah ja hier guck mal, das läuft ja super und so und dann weiß ich auch später stellt man dann fest so
Ja, war im Bug drin irgendwie. Alle unsere Annahmen sind falsch.
Also das wird tatsächlich gemacht ähm in dem Moment, wo es um die Optimierung des Guts geht. Also grad die Frage, wie schnell ein Code tatsächlich ist, hängt sehr stark damit zusammen, äh wie gut ähm die die numerische Programmierung dahinter ist, wie gut äh,
Gleichungssysteme tatsächlich von der Software gelöst werden, ob's jetzt Clus Plus oder Vortrag ist oder MetLab oder was auch immer. Und ähm da ist es tatsächlich so, dass man Module nutzen kann, die andere entwickelt haben, genau optimiert,
für solche äh geophysikalischen Anwendungsprobleme. Und ähm dass man da nicht das Rad äh neu erfinden muss und das hilft auf jeden Fall sehr.
Okay, kommen wir noch mal äh weg von der Mathematik, auch wenn das äh spannend ist. Äh vielleicht nochmal kurz Trapp ist eins. So, jetzt ist das ja ähm sozusagen der interessanteste Ort, ist gar nicht so weit weg,
jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres hin, verzichtlich Tage, bis man dauert lange. Ähm aber,
Da sind jetzt viele Planeten. Man versucht ein bisschen herauszufinden, was ist mit denen? Was kann man denn sicher sagen über dieses System, was da so wohl
abgeht, was da so die Realität ist und was sind noch die großen Fragezeichen, vor allem, was kann man daraus lernen? Also wie Lebens,
affin könnte das sein, zum Beispiel.
Also was wir von dem System wissen ist, dass die Planeten wirklich mit dem Stern zusammen entwickelt haben müssen, also sind keine eingefangenen Planeten,
was man zum Beispiel beim beim Pluto auch schon mal suggeriert hat, dass das gar nicht, dass er sich gar nicht wirklich eine Aggressionsscheibe gebildet hat
Ähm das kann man beim Trapis eins-System relativ gut nachvollziehen. Äh wir wissen auch ähm wie stark diese Gezeitenkräfte, die wir vorhin bei den äh Jupitermonden schon mal kurz
besprochen hätten, äh wie stark diese Gezeitenkräfte dort in dem System ist. Das heißt, wir verstehen relativ gut, wie stark die innersten Planeten aufgeheizt werden.
Ähm wir wissen.
Also nur durch die Gravitation aufgeheizt werden, unabhängig von der Sonnenstrahlung.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Ähm wir wissen allerdings auch relativ gut, ähm äh dass es äh der der Stern selber einen Magnetfeld hat, der auch,
praktisch in die Oberfläche von den nächsten Exoplaneten eintaucht,
und auch dort tatsächlich durch elektrische Leitungen an der Oberfläche auch zu weiterem starken Aufheizten führt,
das kann man relativ gut in in Modellen nachvollziehen, ähm das basiert aber auch wieder auf Laborexperimenten, dass man diese Prozesse relativ gut nachvollziehen kann und dadurch können wir,
recht gut die die innersten Planeten in diesem System, gerade wenn's um die Lebensfreudigkeit vom Planeten geht, ausschließen.
Bei den Planeten, die weiter außen sind, die äußersten Planeten, äh die äußersten zwei, drei Planeten, ähm da wissen wir tatsächlich, dass äh dort große Wasservorkommenüser sein müssen,
ob sie gefroren sind oder flüssig sind. Das ist leider eine ganz andere Frage. Und ähm da brauchen wir mehr Beobachtungsdaten, um da was sagen zu können, zum Beispiel, ob die vielleicht eine Atmosphäre haben oder kalte Eiskrustenoberflächen haben.
Spannende ist wirklich, diese Planeten in der Mitte, diese zwei, drei in der Mitte von dem System, wo die Temperaturen genau richtig sein müssten, dass flüssiges Wasser möglich wäre.
Und ähm da können wir von unserer Modellierung her nur sagen, dass es wirklich heiße Kandidaten sind.
Wir brauchen aber die Beobachtung. Wir brauchen die Beobachtungsdaten von den Atmosphären und äh da wird halt ähm nächstes Jahr hoffentlich das äh James Web äh Weltraumteleskop, was jetzt diesen Dezember,
äh gestartet,
gelauncht wird da werden wir hoffentlich dann Daten finden und das das macht dieses System so unglaublich interessant weil wir die die Randbedingungen des Systems sehr gut verstehen.
Also wir können Planeten ausschließen, aber es gibt zwei, drei Planeten in der Mitte von dem System, die einfach unglaublich interessant sind.
Hier vor drei Sendungen mit Günther Hasinger drüber gesprochen über
äh Teleskop und was so die Ziele sind und eins der großen vier äh Bereiche, in denen halt James Web Fortschritte machen soll, ist eben konkret die äh Beobachtung von Exoplaneten, äh James Webtelskope sind Infrarot Teleskop und kann halt,
sehr fein auflösen, sehr viel feiner als das äh andere Teleskope bisher konnten. Wenn man jetzt sagt, okay 40 Lichtjahre entfernt, Trapp ist eins,
Mit dem James Webtelskop auf dieses System, was könnte dabei rauskommen an Informationen, die man jetzt noch nicht hat.
Das ist auch immer noch ähm eine Sache, dass auch mit dem James Verb Teleskop werden wir einzelne ähm Atmosphärengase wahrscheinlich bestimmen können oder das hoffen wir auf jeden Fall bei dem Trapistein-System.
Also von den einzelnen Planeten von Trapp ist eins. Planeten. Mhm.
Einzelnen Planeten ganz genau,
aber die Komplexität der Daten die wir jetzt von dem Spektrum, vom Mars, von der Atmosphäre oder von der Venus haben, werden wir nicht haben, weil wir einfach viele Störungen haben und die Lichtquelle einfach relativ schwach ist.
Das heißt ähm wir werden aber hoffentlich einzelne Gase bestimmen können und das wird uns schon helfen,
zu unterscheiden, wie die Oberflächen sich weiter oder die Atmosphären sich weiterentwickelt haben von den Planeten, zum Beispiel, ob eine Atmosphäre gleich Sauerstoff hat.
Auf der Erde. Sauerstoff hat sich ja durch die Entwicklung des Lebens an der Oberfläche erst gebetet. Also wenn man sich die frühe Erde anschaut, äh dann sieht man keinen Sauerstoff in der Atmosphäre,
Das Stickstoff gewesen, äh wahrscheinlich auch CO2 in größeren Mengen, eventuell auch Methan.
Also der Sauerstoff war schon da, aber war eigentlich eine Atmosphäre.
Genau, also es gibt äh der der Planet selber besteht tatsächlich äh hauptsächlich aus Sauerstoff,
das Element, das am meisten chemische Element, das am meisten in der Erde vorkommt, aber wirklich O zwei, das was wirkt wirklich zum Leben brauchen, ist erst durchleben durch Laualgen im Ozean entstanden.
Und wenn wir jetzt Sauerstoff an einem anderen Planeten messen würden, wäre das natürlich erstmal eine Sensation.
Muss aber nicht unbedingt bedeuten, dass es dort auch Leben gibt oder auch Photosynthese gibt, was halt bei uns im Sauerstoff äh.
Aber würde auf jeden Fall alle schon wieder total nervös machen, die Information.
Ganz genau, interessant wäre es dann halt Kombination von Gasen zu messen, ne, also wenn man jetzt Sauerstoff und Methan zum Beispiel zusammen messen würde, was beides ähm auf eine für eine biotische Aktivität hindeuten könnte,
aber sich gegenseitig auslöschen, also Methan und Sauerstoff nebeneinander reagieren miteinander. Dann könnte man dadurch,
eine stärkere Vermutung anstellen, dass es dort Leben geben könnte. Und das wäre eine unglaublich spannende Sache.
Okay, alle sind äh scharf auf Trappist eins, aber wir haben ja schon äh erwähnt, gibt ja auch noch einen anderen interessanten Kandidaten, nämlich Proxima Zentauri.
Weil's halt so nah dran ist. Das sind, glaube ich, so vier, fünf äh Lichtjahre in der Größenordnung, dass du quasi umme Ecke äh in Weltraumsprache.
Ähm was was weiß man denn dort äh über diese Exoplanetenkonstellation?
Genau, also bei wurde vor ähm einigen Jahren auch ähm fünf Jahre ist es, glaube ich, her, ein Exoplanet gefunden. Hinter sich,
dem Planeten kennen wir tatsächlich nur die Information, wie stark der Planet den Stern zum Schwanken anregt. Also wir können praktisch eine Idee davon haben, was die Masse von dem Planeten ist. Wir wissen's aber nicht genau.
Und das ist genau das Problem ähm.
Müssen wir das nicht genau, wenn da so nah dran ist.
Bei den Trapisplaneten ist äh der Vorteil, dass der Planeten wirklich in dem Orbit vor dem Stern ihre Laufbahn ziehen. Und dadurch können wir praktisch sehen, wie groß ist der Planet, weil er einen bestimmten Bereich des Sterns verdunkelt.
Und prox über ist anders gekippt sozusagen.
Ganz genau. Wir sehen es.
Obendrauf. Ah ja. Mhm.
Können nur sehen, was es praktisch dieser Schwankungsbereich des Sterns. Und es gibt einen gewissen Massebereich, der dafür in Frage kommt. Wir wissen aber tatsächlich nicht zu hundert Prozent, dass es ein Gesteinsplanet ist. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist aber relativ hoch.
Was wir mittlerweile auch wissen ist, dass es dort ähm scheinbar einen zweiten Exoplaneten gibt. Ähm das ist aber noch nicht zu 100 Prozent bestätigt. Der äh allerdings um einiges massereicher ist und äh wieder so eine super Erde darstellt.
Und es gibt noch andere.
Also der Begriff Supererde sagt wirklich nur.
Supergroße Erde.
Einfach größer. Nicht toller. Ganz genau.
Super Erde ist äh der Begriff, der bedeutet, dass ein Planet äh größer als eine Erdmasse ist äh oder oder ähm massereich jetzt eine Erdmasse ist, bis zu ungefähr zehn Erdmassen.
Und äh das ist eine Klasse von Planeten, die man tatsächlich nicht kannte, bevor man die ersten Exemplaten entdeckt hatte und bevor man CoRo7 B und Kepler 10 B die ersten zwei Gesteinsplaneten entdeckt hat, die beide solche Supererden sind.
Ganz genau.
Und ähm bei ist halt das Spannende, dass der Planet so unglaublich nahe dran ist. Also auch wenn wir tatsächlich nicht genau wissen, wie groß der Planet ist und die Masse nicht genau bestimmen können.
Einfach die Tatsache, dass dort ein Planet ist, der wahrscheinlich in einem Massebereich ist, der ein Gesteinsplanet sein könnte.
Ähm der eventuell flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche haben könnte, weil er tatsächlich in einem Abstand von dem Sternkreis wo flüssiges Wasser möglich wäre. Allein das macht diesem Planeten unglaublich äh interessant.
Und ähm klar kann man sich fragen, warum fliegt man nicht einfach hin? Ähm das ist so der nächste Nachbarstern. So weit weg ist er doch gar nicht.
Wenn schon das Licht fast 54. Lichtjahre braucht.
Genau ähm in Star Trek ist das kein Problem, aber für uns ähm kann man sich vorstellen, äh wie weit es eigentlich Pluto entfernt von der Sonne,
und ähm der dir Abstand zu ungefähr achttausend mal der Abstand von Pluto zur Sonne. Denkt man sich nur gut 8000 Mal klingt das immer noch nie so wahnsinnig viel,
aber die äh Mission ähm,
tatsächlich dem Pluto vor nicht allzu langer Zeit besucht hat. Hat ungefähr zehn Jahre benötigt, um von der Erde zum Pluto zu kommen. Das heißt, wenn man das mal 8000 rechnet, ähm dann findet man da relativ schwer einen Geldgeber, der das finanzieren.
80.000 Jahre warten.
Ja ist ein bisschen äh genau bisschen schwierig.
Aber es gibt da tatsächlich Ideen, wie man das vielleicht etwas schneller hinbekommen könnte und es gibt eine Initiative, die nennt sich äh Starshot, ähm die wurde von Steven Hawking und einem amerikanischen Milliardär Yuri Millner ähm und anderen auch geplant,
und da ist immer noch die Hoffnung, dass man da vielleicht innerhalb von einer Generation Information von kriegen könnte.
Und äh das Hauptproblem ist, wenn man äh eine Masse, also eine schwere Sonde hat, die tatsächlich so schnell zu beschleunigen, dass sie auch nur annähernd,
nicht mein zehnte Lichtgeschwindigkeit, aber auch nur annähernd in die Region von Nichtgeschwindigkeiten kommen. Ähm das das können wir einfach, nicht, nicht äh das ist nicht möglich,
technisch. Wenn man sich jetzt aber ganz kleinst äh Körper Minisunden vorstellt, die mit einem Laser beschleunigt werden und damit pratscht die Energie bekommen und dann ist so ein System verlassen können, dann ist die Hoffnung,
Die Technik muss noch entwickelt werden. Ähm aber die Hoffnung ist, dass man dann vielleicht auf ungefähr einen Fünftel der Lichtgeschwindigkeit kommen könnte.
Und dann braucht man schlagartig nur noch 20 Jahre. Bis zum.
Das ist ja dann schon mal so eine Größenordnung mit der die Raumfahrt eigentlich arbeiten kann.
Genau. Bisher ist es noch rein spekulativ, weil die Technik dafür noch entwickelt werden muss. Die Materialien, die diese Geschwindigkeiten aushalten können, müssen noch entwickelt werden.
Aber bisher ist man da noch recht optimistisch, dass man zumindest von diesen 80.000 Jahren auch vielleicht ein paar hundert Jahre runterkommen können,
Das wäre schon tatsächlich eine andere Sache.
Also es ist so diese Idee, so ein großes äh Lichtsegel zu haben, wo man von hinten mit einem dicken Laser reinballert und durch äh einfach das Anstoßen der von Ton mehr oder weniger die Geschwindigkeit dieses äh Raumfahrtkörpers zunehmend erhöht.
Bis er eben fünftel der Lichtgeschwindigkeit erreicht.
Genau das ist das Ziel, um innerhalb von 20 Jahren zu reisen zu können. Ob man das schafft, ist eine andere Frage, weil die Sonnensäge dürfen auch wieder nicht schwer sein. Die Masse ist wieder das Hauptproblem. Aber da gibt's vielleicht noch eine Hoffnung.
Hm. Genau, es gibt ja immer Hoffnung, äh ist immer jemandem was eingefallen bisher. Ähm ich vermute mal, du bist da wahrscheinlich,
dem Planeten auch mit der Modellierung dran.
Eigentlich jetzt nochmal einen Riesenvorteil oder Vorteil vielleicht gar nicht so groß dadurch, dass dieser Stern so nah dran ist, müsste das ja eigentlich jetzt der der Stern sein, den man eigentlich am besten kennt, oder? Ist das so?
Also für die Nachbarsterne, also äh Alpha Zentari ist ja ein Dreier äh Stern und Alpha Zentari A und B ähm das sind dann wieder größere Massereiche, Sterne, ähm Energie,
reichere Sterne. Die kann man relativ gut bestimmen können. Äh proxymäßig ist ein bisschen schwierig,
Genau und ähm tatsächlich spannenderweise,
sind auch die die Daten für grade für die Zusammensetzung von dem Stern schwanken auch je nachdem wann man sich den Stern tatsächlich genau anschaut.
Und äh da passieren auch interessante Sachen in dem Stern selber und auch da wird wieder viel ist wieder viel Forschung dahinter zu verstehen, wie tatsächlich das das Spektrum von einem Stern, das man misst mit der Zirkulation im Inneren von seinem Stern tatsächlich zusammenhängt.
Das heißt, ist auch noch mal so ein Sonderfall, diese Sonne. Nicht einfach so ein Durchschnittsteil, was hier so normal verhält, sondern es nervt dann auch noch mit mit Abweichung.
Würde's eher sagen, es ist ein interessanter Stern dadurch.
Jetzt müssen wir ja zwangsläufig hier so ein bisschen philosophieren, nicht? Weil vieles wissen wir nicht. Jetzt haben wir ja viel drüber gesprochen, welche Ansätze es gibt
sehr viel hängen von zukünftigen Missionen ab und natürlich.
Auch äh wie schnell man mit diesen Simulationen vorankommt. Das hängt dann wiederum sehr an der Entwicklung der Computertechnik oder wie viel Rechenkapazität überhaupt so zur Verfügung gestellt wird der Wissenschaft.
Was sind jetzt so deine Einschätzung? Einfach so aus dem, was man so weiß und wie sich das jetzt so alles in dieser relativ kurzen Zeit so entwickelt hat. Was,
könnte da,
realistischerweise sein. Ich weiß, dass es mit dieser Spekulation immer so eine Sache und wenn man da nicht die Daten hat, sonst könnte es so sein und es könnte so sein. Aber ähm was ist denn so das Gefühl? Das könnte man ja vielleicht auch mal abklopfen.
So was wie eine Erde da oder woanders.
Also erstmal zu der zu der Frage mit der mit der Datenlage und äh wie viel man spekuliert und wie viel man tatsächlich bestimmen kann.
Das erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen daran, was wir über die Eismonde im äußeren Sonnensystem wussten, bevor das äh Zeitalter der Weltraumfahrt gestartet ist.
Da hatten wir tatsächlich mehr oder weniger genau die gleichen Informationen mit genau den gleichen Beobachtungsdaten, die wir jetzt von den Exoplaneten haben,
Wir konnten genauso Masse und Radius bestimmen. Wir konnten genauso über Spektroskopie Informationen von der Oberfläche von den Körpern sammeln. Und,
Danach hat sich vieles bestätigt in den letzten Jahrzehnten, aber es gab auch große Überraschungen. Und gerade die Tatsache, dass so viele Körper im äußeren Sonnensystem flüssiges Wasser unterhalb der Oberfläche haben,
ist die riesengroße Überraschung schlechthin. Das hat man vorher nicht erwartet. Und genauso wird es uns sicherlich bei den Exoplaneten auch gehen, dass die Daten, die wir jetzt haben,
erlauben uns schon eine relativ gute erste Charakterisierung,
die die erste grobeinschätzung von dem Planeten, genauso wie die erste Grubeinschätzung von vor 100 Jahren von den Eismonden, ist sicherlich nicht so weit weg,
aber diese feinen Details ähm die sind viel, viel schwieriger natürlich ähm herzuleiten und,
Frage, ob's eine zweite Erde geben könnte, also eine Erde, die praktisch genau die gleiche Voraussetzung hat wie unsere Erde, um Leben zu entwickeln. Das kann ich mir tatsächlich sehr gut vorstellen.
Ob sich tatsächlich Leben bildet, das ist noch mal eine ganz, ganz andere Frage und die können wir zur Zeit einfach nicht beantworten,
Wahrscheinlichkeit von 100 Prozent, wenn alles gegeben ist, das Leben entsteht.
Na ja, ich sage mal so, wenn wir Spuren von Leben aufm Mars ähm finden sollten, die darauf hindeuten, dass früher als der Mars mal bewohnbar war, weil er flüssiges Wasser hatte, wenn sich dort auch Leben gebildet hat, dann deutet es darauf hin, dass es sehr wahrscheinlich ist.
Dem Moment, wo's flüssiges Wasser gibt, wo's äh die Bausteine des Lebens gibt, äh chemische, komplexe Verbindungen gibt,
dann sofort Leben entsteht, wäre sehr wahrscheinlich. Aber was passiert, wenn wir in unserem Sonnensystem, egal wo wir schauen, auch bei den Eismuten nirgendswo Leben finden, dann ist es wieder unwahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber man kann keine Wahrscheinlichkeit herleiten, solange man nicht mindestens ein zweites Mal Leben irgendwo entdeckt hat.
Von wie vielen Planeten im Universum kann man denn jetzt ausgehen? Ich meine vor 20 Jahren wusste man eben nicht, gibt's überhaupt welche?
Jetzt hat man so viele gefunden. Ähm das kann man auch bestimmt ganz gut hochrechnen von den viertausend, die wir jetzt äh so gesehen haben.
Pi mal Daumen genauso viele wie Sterne.
Einzelne Planeten.
Ganz Planeten, die auch erdähnlich sind.
Also konkret die erdähnlichen. Genauso viel wie Sterne, also für jeden Stern gibt's auch irgendwie einen im Schnitt.
Er hat ähnlich bedeutet wie der praktischen Gesteinsplanet, der, wenn er in einem richtigen Orbit ist, auch flüssiges Wasser an der Oberfläche rein theoretisch haben könnte. Das scheint wirklich sehr wahrscheinlich zu sein.
Und wie viel Planeten an sich? Könnte man so finden, wenn man das hochrechnet? Also mit all den Gasriesen und so weiter noch dazu.
So viele wie Sterne, die wir beobachten können. Tatsächlich ist es relativ schwer, eine Grenze nach oben zu ziehen. Und fast alle.
Also ich dachte, es gibt jetzt schon so so viele erdähnliche, wie es Sterne gibt.
Fast alle Sterne haben mehrere Planeten soweit wir wissen, also viel mehr als wir früher gedacht hätten,
und äh dementsprechend ähm wenn fast jeder Stern oder die Hälfte der Sterne im Planetensystem haben mit mehreren Sternen sind's fünf äh mit mehreren Planeten, fünf Planeten sind's zehn Planeten,
Dann ähm kann man sich entsprechend ausrechnen.
Also insgesamt so fünf, fünf oder zehn Mal so viel, wie es Sterne gibt. Also oder mal anders ausgedrückt. Es ist jetzt relativ klar, wo's so Sternen gibt, gibt's auch Planeten.
Sagen wir einfach, es ist die gleiche Größenordnung.
Okay. Ja, aber das ist ja auch schon mal eine interessante Information, weil da war man sich ja nicht so sicher, ob denn irgendwie wirklich.
Wusste man vorher überhaupt nicht. Genau und äh grad die Frage, wie wahrscheinlich es ist, dass man halt diese diese erdähnlichen Gesteinsplaneten hat. Ähm da ist man früher davon ausgegangen, dass es eher unwahrscheinlich ist und und äh wir eher die Ausnahme bilden und das scheint aber nicht der Fall zu sein.
Das macht nämlich jetzt unser Sonnensystem wieder mal ein Momentchen normaler und in gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch ein beruhigender ähm Gedanke
dass wir hier ein relativ normales äh System haben, grade für äh eine Modellierung,
Ja, also man kann sozusagen von den Beobachtungen, die wir hier gemacht haben, in all den Messungen, den ganzen äh Erkenntnissen, das was man hier konkret überprüfen kann, kann man eben auch sehr viele Schlüsse
auf den Rest des Universums äh ziehen und das scheint einfach so der Normalzustand zu sein,
Gedanken irgendwie, dass wir hier so in keine Ausnahme sind, finde ich irgendwie bisschen beruhigender, auch wenn's am Ende natürlich auch vollkommen egal ist. Ähm,
Also mal abgesehen davon, dass das eben so dieses Potenzial leben und so weiter hat. Was macht denn diese erdähnlichen
Planeten jetzt so sehr viel interessanter für
deine Arbeit. Ich meine, man könnte ja sicherlich auch, was ist ein Gasriesen, auch eine ganze Menge Informationen rausziehen und da sie sich ja sogar noch ein bisschen einfacher beobachten lassen, wäre das ja eigentlich eine sehr naheliegende Disziplin. Warum hast du dich denn jetzt so auf diesen erdähnlichen so,
eingeschossen.
Also ich find's halt spannend, äh zu sehen, dass wir in unserem Sonnensystem,
vier Gesteinsplaneten haben, also Merkur Venus, Maß und Erde, die sich alle vier doch sehr unterschiedlich entwickelt haben, obwohl sie aus mehr Damien gleichen Material entstehen.
Bei den Gasriesen, also zumindest so, wie wir sie äh auch von Beobachtungen her verstehen können,
scheint es in den geradlinigeren Weg zu gehen in der Entwicklung,
Während äh gerade bei den Gesteinsplaneten ähm die Wege, die der Gesteinsplanet gehen kann oder die Oberfläche, ob's Plattentektone gibt, ob es Vulkanismus gibt, ob Leben an der Oberfläche entstehen kann, so unterschiedlich variabel ist
und von sehr vielen anderen auch äußeren inneren Bedingungen abhängt. Das finde ich finde ich extrem spannend
Natürlich ist die Frage nach der Bewundbarkeit von dem Planeten eventuell Leben auf einem anderen Planeten zu finden. Einer der der Hauptdriver für diese Frage.
Gar keine Frage.
Mhm. Jetzt ist natürlich diese ganze,
Frage nach Leben und ich weiß, das ist jetzt nicht so dein dein Feld, Astrobiologie ist ja noch mal äh eine ganz andere äh Disziplin, aber das spielt ja hier alles auch so ein bisschen mit rein. Ähm,
Gibt es denn aus den aus dieser Forschung schon in irgendeiner Form Indizien, dass ein.
Leben, was anders funktioniert, als das, was wir von unserem System her kennen, irgendwie eine Option ist. Äh oder gibt's irgendwie Dinge, die das,
ausschließen oder ist es einfach allgemein noch offen und man kann darüber wenig sagen. Es gab ja mal
paar Jahren mal diese fälschlicherweise von der NASA publizierte Studie, die ja so glaube ich nahegelegt hat, dass,
Ähm genau, was war das?
Genau der so ein asinbasiertes äh äh Leben möglich ist. Das wurde ja dann wieder äh äh zurückgezogen. Das war ja schon mal so ein kurzer Aufreger, aber so einfach generell ist das natürlich ein interessanter Gedanke, dass äh,
dieses Leben, also dieses sich selbst in irgendeiner Form weiter äh entwickelnde Aktivität von von,
Materie, um's mal allgemeiner zu formulieren, eben auch noch auf was anderem basieren kann als eben auf diesen Aminosäuren und so weiter, wie wir das hier so.
Ja, da beschäftigen sich natürlich sehr viele damit und schauen, warum sind wir denn eigentlich Kohlenstoffbasiert? Äh warum benötigen wir Wasser? Was sind eigentlich die positiven Eigenschaften davon?
Und ähm wenn man sich ganz allgemein überlegt, wie so ein Lebenszyklus funktionieren könnte, was was benötigt man? Man benötigt ähm zum Beispiel einen,
so etwas wie eine Zelle, in der ähm Bedingungen, Drucktemperatur, Salzgehalt, was auch immer ähm relativ konstant gehalten werden kann, also um überhaupt in der Umgebung überleben zu können.
Ähm musst oder müsste leben generell irgendeinen abschließbaren Bereich ähm entwickeln können. Also das Leben auf der Erde hat er Zellen entwickelt dafür.
Dann kann man überlegen, okay, was für äh Eigenschaften braucht ähm so ein Material, um wie eine Zelle zu funktionieren, dass man vielleicht auch Wechselwirkungen nach außen hat, also Flüssigkeiten zum Beispiel,
ausgleichen kann und Ähnliches. Und wenn man dann schaut, ähm welche chemischen Elemente sind da eigentlich prädestiniert dafür, um diese komplexen Systeme überhaupt erst zu bilden?
Da ist Kohlenstoff tatsächlich prädestiniert dafür.
Weil da einfach so reaktionsfreudig ist, sich mit allem verbindet.
Genau, aber auch stabil ist. Er kann ähm äh Doppelbindung eingehen, er kann unglaublich komplexe Moleküle bilden,
und ähm Silizium zum Beispiel im Vergleich wird ja in der Science-Fiction gerne als Alternative zu Kohlenstoff gesehen, ähm hat auch viele Ähnlichkeiten mit Kunststoff, aber hat diese Möglichkeit nicht.
Und ähm grade was so die Silizium basiertes Leben angeht, denke ich mir immer naja an der Oberfläche fast alles
Gestein einer Oberfläche, ob's jetzt der Sand am Strand ist oder was auch immer besteht aus Silizium und trotzdem hat Leben kein Silizium eingebaut.
Ist natürlich kein Ausschlusskriterium, gar keine Frage.
Mal ein interessanter Blickwinkel.
Und ähm ein anderer Blickwinkel, den ich ähm ganz spannend finde, ist, dass die chemischen Elemente, die tatsächlich im Universum am meisten vertreten sind,
fast 1:1 die chemischen Elemente, die auch am meisten im menschlichen oder generell im Leben auf der Erde vertreten sind,
Also Sauerstoff, Wasserstoff, ähm Stickstoff, äh Phosphor, Schwefel,
neben dem coolen Stoff sind halt alles auch genau die Elemente, die am am leichtesten verfügbar sind.
Und nicht nur jetzt bei uns, sondern generell.
Generell im Universum, generell in jedem äh oder ja doch eigentlich in jedem ähm Sonnensystem äh würde man davon ausgehen oder jedem Sternsystem.
Ist es natürlich so, wenn man jetzt von von Bedingungen an der Oberfläche ausgeht, also von einem, was ich jetzt wieder in den erdähnlichen Planeten äh nennen würde, also ein Gesteinsplanet, wo man halt eher da überlegt, ob Leben eine Oberfläche entstehen kann.
Dort werden wahrscheinlich wirklich die besten Bedingungen für kunstoffbasiertes Leben und äh Wasser, was halt als zum Lösen von Mineralien aus äh Gestein sehr, sehr wichtig ist, ähm schon die prädestinierten Kandidaten.
Sich aber Leben vorstellt, dass unter ganz anderen Bedingungen sich entwickeln würde. Dann haben wir schlagartig äh andere Eigenschaften, die wichtiger sind und dann ist vielleicht äh Silizium,
wiederum interessanter. Das heißt, die Frage ist eher für mich nicht unbedingt, ob wir unterschiedliches oder komplett unterschiedliches Leben,
auf einem Planeten genau wie der Erde erwarten würden, sondern eher unter welchen unterschiedlichen Bedingungen,
Sind andere Eigenschaften von chemischen Elementen wichtiger als jetzt an der Oberfläche von der Erde. Und da gibt's vielleicht Möglichkeiten.
Schwierig sein dürfte, das überhaupt erstmal zu erkennen wenn man gar nicht weiß, wo wonach man
suchen soll. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Problem, weil man hat nicht diese klaren Indikatoren, von denen man weiß so, ah ja, okay, genau das verweist ja jetzt äh auf Leben. Es gab ja jetzt äh
auch ähm jüngst bei der Beobachtung der Venus so verschiedene äh Rückmeldungen, wo vermutet wurde, ah okay, gibt es Verbindungen, die relativ klar auf Leben hinweisen, weil wir die ohne Leben so äh diese Verbindung so nicht gesehen haben. Ich nicht so ganz so sicher, ob sich das überhaupt bestätigt hat. Ich glaube, da gab's
dran.
Es hat sich leider nicht bestätigt, hat aber da auch wieder eine neue Forschung angekurbelt, weil gerade dieses Gas, was in der Venus leider dann doch nicht entdeckt wurde, äh.
Genau das war's. Mhm.
Könnte halt ähm wenn wir das sehr stark in einem bei einem Exoplaneten eine Atmosphäre entdecken würden, dort vielleicht eine gute Signatur für möglicherweise Leben auf der Oberfläche geben.
Problem ist immer noch, dass eigentlich bei fast allen Gasen gibt es auch immer eine abiotische Erklärung.
Also gerade dieses Gas, äh wo halt über bei der Venus viel spekuliert wurde, kann durch vokanische Ausgasung entstehen.
Methan ist zum Beispiel auch äh ein Gas, was grade im Zusammenhang mit Maß oft diskutiert wird, ob mit Harngase aufm Mars existieren und wenn ja, ähm vielleicht biotisch ein Ursprung sein könnten, weil auf der Erde fast alles Meter an von Leben,
produziert wird, aber eben nicht alles. Und es sind.
Von Kühen sozusagen.
Kommt nicht alles von den Kühen, es sind geringer Prozentsatz, aber ein gewisser Prozentsatz von den Methangasen auf der Erde werden durch die Erde selber produziert,
durch Geologie und ähm deswegen ist auch Methan selber kein perfektes Gas, um auf Leben auf einmal einem Planeten hinzuweisen.
Okay, also viele Rätsel bleiben noch äh erhalten. Wenn ich das richtig äh äh sehe, gibt's an der FU demnächst auch einen neuen äh Studiengang, der Leuten, die Gelegenheit bieten soll, äh hier noch tiefer einzusteigen. Kannst du dazu was sagen?
Genau, wir richten gerade einen Masterstudiengang ein ähm in englischsprachiger Masterstudiengang wird es sein zum Thema äh Science ist ein Space Exploration,
tatsächlich viele von den Themen, äh die wir heute hier angerissen haben, auch eine Rolle spielen werden. Ähm der Masterstudiengang ist offen für Studenten, ähm
die
beliebigen naturwissenschaftlichen Fächern kommen, können aus der Geologie sein, aber auch ein physikalisch, chemischer Hintergrund, biologischer Hintergrund, ähm steht äh ein naturwissenschaften frei der Studiengang.
Ähm dort arbeiten wir tatsächlich ähm auch mit unterschiedlichen Forschern an außer universitären Einrichtungen in Berlin zusammen,
Also wir haben ähm auch äh vortragende vom Museum für Naturkunde zum Beispiel vom deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt,
damit die Studierenden möglichst breites äh Spektrum an Vorlesungen ähm hören können und das geht von äh geologischen Entwicklungen ähm astronomischen Vorlesungen, ähm Planetenexploration,
Fernerkundungsmethoden ähm also das gesamte äh Spektrum wird in den Masterstudiengang vertreten sein.
Mhm. Wer äh was trägt äh das Museum für eine Naturkunde äh zum Beispiel dazu bei?
Zum Beispiel von für Naturkunde geht es um Impaktforschung,
oder auch um eine äh Feldexkursion, um sich einen äh Implakater und und vulkanische Krater,
äh Deutschland anzuschauen und zu sehen, äh live zu erleben, ähm wie sich die Oberfläche entsprechend ähm diesen ähm geologischen Prozessen anpasst.
Wahrscheinlich auch die Meteoritensammlung äh mit äh zum Tragen
gibt mir die Gelegenheit nochmal auf Raumzeit 6undachtzig zu verweisen, wo ich mit Ansgar gesprochen habe, äh über Meteoriten und äh wie man die alle hier so eingesammelt bekommt, unter anderem den man,
Dächer abfegt und so. Großartiges Gespräch auch,
Ja, super, viel Erfolg mit dem äh Studiengang. Ist das schwierig, so einen neuen Studiengang ähm durchgesetzt zu bekommen?
Würde eher sagen, dass es eine sehr spannende Aufgabe. Ähm es ist auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit involviert ist, aber da dieser Studiengang bisher in Deutschland komplett fehlt,
auch in Europa kaum äh Planetologie studiert werden kann, ähm ist das eine Herausforderung, äh die sehr dankbar ist,
Und ich freue mich sehr darauf, dass wir in einem Jahr den Studiengang dann tatsächlich haben werden und bin sehr gespannt, wie's läuft.
Ist das äh schwierig da so die Unterstützung der Universität dafür zu bekommen oder ist so das Bewusstsein für diese Themen schon da?
Nee, auf jeden Fall, das wurde komplett unterstützt und ähm ähm ich denke, das äh wird auch den dem Berliner Raum sehr stärken,
Dass wir diesen äh Masterstudiengang haben und äh auch da arbeiten wir halt mit unterschiedlichen ähm Instituten zusammen, um auch die,
Praktika oder Praktikantenstellen zum Beispiel zu ermöglichen für die Studierenden, dass man auch zum Beispiel bei der Esel ein Praktikum machen kann oder beim Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt,
um ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, was man nach dem Studium denn machen möchte.
Mhm. Klingt super,
Ja genau, vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführung zur Exoplaneten insbesondere den erdähnlichen und was so äh von der Forschung dort in der nächsten Zeit so zu erwarten ist?
Ist ja alles sehr viel äh fällig. Wir äh sind weiter dabei und drücken vor allem dem James Web Teleskop jetzt, die die Daumen, weil das scheint ja auch in dieser Disziplin wirklich eine.
Schlüsselmission seien zu äh können und hoffen natürlich alle, dass wir hier auch noch viel drüber berichten können.
Ja, ich bedanke mich auch.
Genau und ich bedanke mich wie immer fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Bald geht's wieder weiter und.